next
submitter um isn't in the uh paper order
of speakers to be heard and there was an
administrative error there on our
part but is on page one two six nine
of board books uh
learning differences and uh
chris and lisa welcome along thank you
we've got um
10 minutes uh we do ring a bell at five
that's that's not
the graham norton chair signal it's
really just a reminder where you are
through the process
if you go to 10 that's fine it's just we
won't have time to ask any questions
um but really thank you for for this uh
the submission
and uh really the floor is yours now
thanks thank you
so that's okay there yeah so um thank
you very much for this opportunity
i'm here representing the trust and lisa
is the
chair of our trust we run a variety of
programs to support
people children to adults with learning
differences in southland
and just to let you know that what we do
in southland is actually not done
anywhere else in new zealand
so um what i was wanting to talk about
we agree with the food options for the
urban play space
and the southern museum and art gallery
but what we're wanting to look at is
like it's adding value to those projects
by including um neurodiversity
the options to support our
neurodiversity community
so that is increasing accessibility so
that they can
use these spaces so where before you are
listening to ccs talk about those
with disabilities with neurodiversity
some people do call them disabilities in
the human rights commission it's
given that that it's under that comes
under that uh word disability we don't
see it that way
but what they do talk about is that it's
hidden so it's not actually
it's not noticed to the same extent so
that's why i'm here today
to increase your awareness about it
so what how we'd like to achieve this
including our neurodiversity and the
planning and implementation of these
projects
is having a voice representing that
community
that person who has lived experience and
also has the ability to coordinate with
all the groups in southland
to bring together the neurodiversity
voice
and be involved in planning and
implementing
the space so that we have increased
accessibility
for all of our community so just to
explain what neurodiversity is
it's a fairly new term that's getting a
lot of recognition in corporate and
education sectors
it is a term that just means people
think and process information in a
different way
that's all it means and under that big
umbrella term
of neurodiversity is uh you can have
people uh dyslexics you can have just
people with dyspraxia
you can have adhd or you can have autism
so the neurodiversity covers all that
all
that whole umbrella now the reason that
it's
important to know about neurodiversity
community is because
research shows that up to 20 of our
community has
a neurodiversity so if we're
sitting in this room here at least six
people
would have a neurodiverse way of
thinking
and uh on one of them so yeah
so i think it's um what it means though
you know for
our neurodeuce community is if we're in
a place where
there's a lot of written material that's
giving instruction
it's really hard to engage with that you
know the written material
so it's how do we change that that
information so it becomes accessible to
everyone you know and it and also
for those with low literacy skills so it
might be also that um
providing within a play space different
types so there's you know a person can
play on their own or in a group
and that's catering to everyone
so it's all about inclusion as well
and it also could mean that someone
who's um challenged with coordination
that if we have you know specialized
equipment that they can
play on that equipment and it's like in
the museum
you know if we've got exhibitions it's
having the
how the information is presented about
the the um
exhibitions is done in a way that will
be accessible and not text heavy
so those are some of the ideas that can
be done it's not they don't have to be
big major things but they as small
things can make a difference
so just to let you know um with the um
with the work that we do down here we
southam has got a lot of expertise
around neurodiversity
compared to the rest of new zealand and
also thinking about how the work that
we've done down here
comes from you know how southand has
this innovative spirit
that we always embrace whether it's our
isolation or
whatever it is and this is this is
similar it's like can we
take the initiative to have in our
planning
and future proofing what we do catering
for our neurodiverse community
so that's up to um you know 20
000 people in southland 20 of the
population
so that's a big chunk of our community
that we need to be
um supporting and you know increasing
accessibility
so it's just um going forward keeping in
mind
um all aspects of our community so that
they're included
and using the expertise that we have
down here to really make
the future proof what we what we want to
do
and i just wanted to show you something
that we did over covert because our
community wasn't
accessing the information the very good
information that was coming out of
wellsealth
so this is this is just information that
came out about staying mentally healthy
and we converted it to this
so it was accessible and that's it
doesn't take much
to make it easier to um to
you know access okay so
thank you thanks chris so so cracking up
on
on on your message and and wanting to
have these
uh issues taken into uh consideration
through the the
city centre master plan and and the play
space
wouldn't it be better if we just
incorporated it into
all our signage yeah yes
yes bearing in mind outdoor play spaces
swimming pools council facilities
absolutely i mean you imagine if we
became like a neurodiversely
you know friendly city just like that
with the signage
and i mean that's what covert showed us
is that to access information we have to
do it in different ways we have to be
you know inclusive and realize that
people do process it in different ways
so it's just it's just celebrating and
you know incorporating that in any of
our design
yep would it be fair to say it's not
just incorporating
those who have various forms of
neurodiversity but also
what some might call a modern attention
span
um and and that you know documents seem
to be scanned very quickly without
seeking the detail whereas if
if the detail is is more simply placed
there that it becomes easier for people
to understand
yeah absolutely and i mean like this
here is done in a learning difference
friendly way but everyone can access it
easier
you know so what you can do to support
um anyone who with neurodiversity is
going to benefit
everyone and can i just follow up on a
point that you started with
this isn't happening anywhere else in
new zealand
no i can't find it um that anyone is
looking at future planning with
neurodiversity it's not really in the
um you know in the infrastructure
you know it's in corporate you know
they're starting to talk about it in
corporate
structure in workplace and in the
education sector but not in this
not that i can find in this sector thank
you council is open for questions
no that's what happens when you explain
things simply
uh look it's a it's a really interesting
point that we've
obviously never had presented to us
before so um
thank you for first of all you you've
written submission
and again our apologies for not picking
up um
on the fact that you want to speak to it
but thanks for coming along this
afternoon
thank you very much
janet would you like to hop on up
welcome jeanette again it's not an
unfamiliar process
for you so you've got 10 minutes
still more of you than there are of us
yeah but you've got a safety barrier and
you can sit down these days
that's true uh well uh good afternoon
everybody and
your worship councillors thank you for
the opportunity
uh to talk to our submission i'm
jeanette malcolm this is jesse hall and
another
member of our trust lindell ludlow is in
the back there somewhere
so as council knows we're the team for
projects saving grace which is proposing
the conversion of a disused building
in south invercargill the old grace
street chapel to be exact
into a community space which will
promote resilience connection
and well-being within the city
it would be a multi-use and highly
flexible space
located alongside south alive and the
pantry
and if you consider the floor plan
that's attached to our submission
you'll note both the size and the number
of spaces that could be provided
we've developed a comprehensive
feasibility study which
points to a strong need for a dedicated
space for youth
the arts physical activity and events as
well
as a hosted community lounge and the
feasibility ins
involved people like mana from evolve
gym at the blues club
who's run out of space mikhail from
zumba who asked for an update recently
and wrote in reply
it's such a great project and i know
there is a huge
need for it i would be moving all of my
take home classes right away
special needs people who have had their
day centres closed
grey power so they could go to where the
majority of their members are
red cross refugee program to enable
community connections for former
refugees
and the arts who need studio and class
spaces and youth
the fact that they have nowhere now
should be enough said
we got strong support from them and from
the organizations that work with youth
and in terms of geography the use of the
space would of course be open to
everyone
and we know from the south alive and
pantry experience its location won't be
a deterrent for those in other parts of
the city
but in this location what it would do is
give people living in the south
the opportunity to have facilities they
can actually access
we believe there's a strong alignment
with council's criteria for supporting
projects
namely that the project supports the
well-being of
all the community and the four
well-beings
so enable would enable council to meet
the local meet its local government act
obligations
in a community which is 35 of
invercargill's population
but which due to 85 of that population
living in
high levels of deprivation on a national
standard
cannot easily access many of the
council's other projects
there's a demonstrated need for the
project and a couple of other points
it would also contribute to council's
play strategy
in providing a large covered space for
that
and it could provide a unique tailored
support system for transitioning workers
when ty closes
we've had good and positive discussions
with uh the funding trusts
from ilt and the ilt foundation with
several on-site visits
including from the chair and engagement
and visits from the southern trust ceo
from dunedin and community trust south
and the lottery
community facilities fund but the fact
remains that it's more likely to proceed
if there's some form of council
participation
so what is our request to council at our
last appearance in february we asked the
council buy and own the building
probably using endowment funds at an
amount approximately equal to 0.5
of what is being spent in the cbd this
is a different proposal in that our
trust could now own the building itself
and council could participate in another
way
we haven't been specific in terms of a
dollar amount in our submission because
we
understand the severe limitations
council has
but we are requesting that the project
be added to the ltp
in a way that allows for funding
discussions and in-kind initiatives to
be considered
and that council agrees to work
alongside the funding trusts and
ic2 that's us to further investigate the
options for how it could work in
partnership
and help to fund the project and so in
closing
we aren't just proposing a building with
a collection of spaces available to
groups that don't have any or don't have
enough now
we aren't just proposing a building that
will enable and facilitate community
connections to build
better resilience and mental well-being
it's all of that but it's more
we will do our utmost through private
partnerships and expert assistance
and through working with south
invercargill on our trust
on our trust and in our advisory groups
to make sure it's also
exciting and somewhere that the local
community find inspiring
and that they're proud of and that will
be a great thing for all of invercardo
thank you thanks janet you talked about
um
private partnerships just towards the
end there have there been any
expressions of interest
of those um well we've been talking with
vodafone quite a lot of course because
as council knows they are coming here
for three to six years
and they express strong interest
um but they haven't you know they
obviously want to take things in order
they want to do their research before
they make any
commitments and that's now being pushed
back a bit and there are other
um certainly other ideas and offers
you know to put us in touch with people
but don't really want to go
public on that just yet mr chair fair
enough
councillors it's open to questions from
you
councillor amundsen thanks um
two questions i guess uh the first one
is
around why is this being done kind of
separate i guess to self alive um
and uh the second question is in other
communities around new zealand
which are you know similar in terms of
deprivation to south city
do you know of any places that have
centres like this or some kind of
community facility like this
and the impact that that's had on those
communities
um in relation to south alive um they
were um part of the um
you know the research for the need and
the analysis of that need when we were
doing the feasibility in fact
you know it's south in vicar because we
had jan ormsby as well and in fact your
own tony biddle as well
we're in fact the majority so um so they
strongly support the need for the
project
their issue was twofold one was that
they
they feel that and i agree with them
that a project like this
needs a huge amount of focus and
resource and they simply don't have that
in order to get it over the line
but the full intention is that they
would run it or they'd run the booking
or
that they would be running at the very
least a partnership
and so um and their other concern was
with the building itself
but as you'll know from the feasibility
study we have had a full engineering
report
and we've had the design fix from
kensington engineers
and it's been costed into by the
quantity surveyor so
we don't have you know as it turned out
those concerns about the building were
fairly easily fixed in terms of bringing
it up to 67
of the building code in terms of
other centres around new zealand
we've looked we looked into a few in
terms of design we don't
we haven't looked into them in terms of
what impact did they have on the
community not aware of any studies that
have been done there's been a lot of
research
in australia which you know which we've
certainly looked at in terms of
what creates community resilience and
mental health and that is just the sort
of centre that we're proposing
but to my knowledge isn't that same
research in fact we
we were talking uh initially with steve
giblin
who who's aware of some researchers in
christchurch that this could be a model
for um for looking into that the before
and
after councillor lush you make a very
compelling
argument to and it's a fantastic
proposal to spend some
money and revitalize that community if
you extend that do you think there would
be advantages
to make that area a focus for the new
museum and the new art gallery
is that the right place to put it giving
connectivity and all those concepts
you've brought up there
um i don't think there's any spaces
there but um
i guess you've already got i mean if we
were starting from
um you know from a clean sheet
grassroots maybe but
the thing is that you've already got the
museum in its location so
it probably wouldn't make any sense i
guess to consider
moving that um
what was the other one the museum in
what sorry oh the art gallery
um i'm sure it'd be a great idea
councillor lush but
um um i mean they've got to go somewhere
i suppose like the stadium is where it
is
rugby parks where it is flesh palace is
where it is
um you can't really answer beyond that
okay sorry
thanks for thinking thanks councillor
clark yeah through you chair um
jeanette um i raised this when you did
the la
the last presentation so i guess i'll
just raise it again
um um you sort of answered it with one
of the previous
questions about whether you've got some
um information from
other sites and i know the chair's going
to tell me this needs to be a question
but
um there are other community hubs
especially in the north island
and low dip or high deprivation areas
and i think it would be helpful if you
could
access them to see how they set up and
how they're funded and what
outcomes they've got i think it would
really enhance you aren't you case to do
that
so if you could do that i think that
would be really helpful
i think that's an excellent idea um to
date of course
apart from a small grant that paid for
the engineer you know this has been a
volunteer
project over the huge number of hours
over a year so
we've been a bit limited really um in
that but going forward and before
anything starts and indeed the very next
step
i think we wanted to do this first so
council wasn't surprised but
is to call a proper public meeting you
know there's been a lot of public input
92 youth and 25 organizations but really
in the way we did south alive the next
step is to call
a full-on public meeting so you know and
then see who wants to be involved
in an ongoing way as vari parts of
various groups and so
you know one of those could be a
research group yeah
thank you thank you thank you for your
submission
uh thank you both for taking the time to
come along and speak to it and answer
our questions we appreciate it
thank you
mr hodgkinson again sir you're not
unfamiliar with our process you know
we've got 10 minutes
take a seat the clock's ticking thank
you very much
um
thank you for the opportunity mayor
councillors
um i apologize for this um um
waiting for some dentures so there we go
if you could just make sure that
microphone was up close
yes thank you thank you um my interest
is as it always is uh is trying to
encourage
uh the different uh territorial
authorities the district council
um your sales and environment south and
uh to in your plant long term planning
and these 10 year plans i realize that
there are
evolve and they're working project that
always gets updated
there but given the uh transitional
times uh
and uncertain times that we're facing um
i feel that we should be
um giving far more attention uh
to um making um
this city and our province fit for
purpose
for the new green economies and circular
economies
that whether you're uh progressive in
nature
or last cab off the rank we're all going
to end up there
to have to respond to this climate
challenge
that we've got the small window of
opportunity to address
now i notice in there there's a
reference
just in passing hardly more than that
maybe there's more detail there about
dealing with climate change
but um as we've all um
learnt this is um
affecting us just like this worldwide
pandemic
and we've got to get out in front of
that and a 10 year plan
shouldn't be looking at just
the important uh the day-to-day issues
or establishment of infrastructure
or capital expenditure for now we've got
to look forward and plan
progressively where we want to be what
sort of city
its appearances what is it going to look
in 20
or 50 years time it's not like a three
year time frame that politicians
normally work to
for uh politicking purposes um you have
got a
a mandate and an obligation as the other
territorial authorities there to look at
that
and actually plan ahead and i find the
references here very light
and uh and vague to like having to
counter any um increased flooding risk
or implications for drainage
or or levels there but
we've actually got to try and make sure
that we're fit for
purpose and try to lead the pack because
there's a whole lot of marketing
advantages and
looking for a green economy so i'm
suggesting
that not only the city and this province
there we start to look at seeing how we
can reposition ourselves and also
if we adopt some of those practices um
so that we can have
um getting a first adopter or first
mover advantage there
so i think south and um in the wider
sense
should be try to be driving
ecological uh change and putting that
into our communities
and into our commercial things uh there
for for marketing advantage and also
for practical reasons so as far as
invercargill itself
uh there i'll just note the thing there
that i put in under that column
is pedestrianizing the cbd
for extended shopping i know that uh the
the business houses are very
protective of their parking but i think
we've
got to convince them or make
those adjustments so that we can keep
them in there we've got to have
far more interconnected undercover
connections we've got
a few arcades in there i think they
should be built
because of the challenging weather that
we have here
if we want people to stay and and shop
and visitors to spend
more time and spend more money and i
think and i've also been uh um
previously looking at um developing a
laminated wood industry for
saga and south to take advantage of
their um
large quantities of usable
timber to add value to it uh there
so that we can reduce our reliance on
these uh concrete steel
structures there which end of life
that's their problem um and this
also the my other interest is advancing
the idea
of having an industrial vermiculture
industry i.e to harness the green waste
that your council
has in its um uh
transfer station that's not being
utilized
a lot of that material has just been
taken and
and dumped it back over your landfill
which was meant to be closed 20 years
ago so there's a resource it's not being
made into compost
like a lot of other councils or utilized
so what you can do is take that material
and you can combine it as a carbon
product
with protein i.e there's a number of
freezing works in new zealand are
disposing large quantities of woolly
lamb pelts sheep pelts currently
quietly because there's the the
economies of processing them and trying
to market them
are not there at the moment so you've
got two you've got a protein source
available in huge quantities and you've
got your green waste that's not doing
anything
for your ratepayers there the other
component
that could be make vermiculture i.e um
[Music]
tiger worms to break that material which
is combined down
and then separated out so that you can
use that
as a feedstock to create more um
worm eating capabilities for the lack of
a better word
and you get vermicast out of the worms
which is like
equivalent so that we can replace that
an industrial scale
with super phosphate npk
dap all those chemically made synthetic
fertilizers that are
now endangering our waterways
so that's a consequence there is an
economic advantage
that we can be doing at scale to
actually address
that and that model can be used in other
provinces
so there's an economic advantage for the
council and ratepayers
and also as far as wider southland
we should be looking at making themed
cycle trail
developments off that round the mountain
thing which is
effectively not delivered for anybody
what was promised so we've got to theme
them either have circular food
maps for people online or print out so
they can cycle or use their
camper vans to go around and taste
different things
whether it's mutton and winton or
whether it's
venison and tiana or or lamb and pork
and utilise their chefing and the ilt
involved to actually use that as a one
way of encouraging
slow circulation by people that have got
time to indulge in those things or for
educational things
and the other thing at tr now and
finally
is that i'm um i've already made an
initial
um presentation to a group there
a couple of weeks a couple of months ago
um
to look at what we could do to have
tiana as
a an eco town so i'm suggesting that we
actually have that as an eco resort
that we create a lab there instead of
the
tourism and farming sectors that have
meshed and functioned very well in that
isolated area
we also combine that with
researching green practices i.e
regenerative farming
organic farming advanced
green uh tourism initiatives whether
it's hydrogen buses
through the milford and all those
components
can be done within that triangulation
of a city area and then it can be funded
by central government by all these
pots of money that are available
currently to support not only
fiordland and tourism through this
pandemic
but we also tie into other
sources of streams and use that area as
a testing ground as i say for all the
green practices
that we can roll out flip out to wider
southland
and into other provinces in new zealand
and also worldwide
so then you've got three another
advantage to your main tourist town
that you should be well connected to
you've got farming
tourism and you've got a research
capability
which means you'll be hosting people
from other countries and other areas
to on that data that's drawn down from
those areas there
and you could actually have that as an
income source to fill your hotels and tr
now
um and your motels out for conferences
and and the like that is uh thank you
for that
but what i have got here is it in a in a
in detail uh touching on these points
but for the life of us i can't get your
it or your staff to get it out of here
and print it it's 14 pages so with your
forbearance
no you see the content we'll we'll work
with uh you to take that off find some
way to
make it available to counselors i just
want to open the discussion
because i'm going to be taking these
elements up with environment southland
and tourism and farming interests so
you're the first people
that i'm just wanting to open that
discussion with thank you mr
green future and and we appreciate the
submission
and the time you've taken to come along
unfortunately we don't actually have
time for questions now that's how you
use your ten minutes that's that's fine
uh but also wish you
uh continued speedy recovery from your
accident as well thank you for that
marion
welcome along
can i just start with a question of
clarification it's
are there two submissions from anderson
house trust or am i
misreading it thank you
can i begin yes please uh councillors
mia
and councillors and staff i thank you
for hearing us today
uh we're very keen for you to present
this opportunity
to here to enable you to hear about the
things that have gone
on in the last three years
the most important point we need to make
to you
and i know that there's four people here
who weren't in the council
in 2018 is the inconsistent figures that
are being presented
now in this year's long-term plan 2131
there's a figure of 900 of 1.2 million
to upgrade anderson house a figure of
500
000 was quoted by the chief executive at
a meeting of
u3a recently in the 2018 long-term plan
page 18
a figure of 2 million was quoted
and the and then there was another
figure on page 22
of 1.7 million and it was part of an
option one
which was approved by council by this
council following hearings
and i'll remind you of the other
commitments that this council approved
at that time
quoting from a letter on the submissions
to
everyone who submitted uh alternative
water supply
anderson house additional pool splash
palace additional funding south and
indoor leisure center
living dinosaurs regional storage
facility and museum replacement and
there were timelines on those
anderson house uh trust was informed by
staff members at last meeting
that the current amount of 900 will only
cover earthquake strengthening and basic
maintenance
and you will have seen the pictures of
the state of this house
that belongs to all of us there's
a lot of work required on the building
before it can be opened to the public
and the remaining 300 000 in the budget
will not cover
that work um
where is the budget for additional work
uh
when will the remaining work be
scheduled and will the public have to
wait another three years
for this work to be done at the 6th of
october
council meeting of the infrastructure
committee there was a deputation from
the anderson house trust
and councillors unanimously voted to get
anderson house
open to the public and this this this
decision was reported
in the southern times and uh a dollar
the dollar amount quoted in this item
refers to 400 for maintenance
and a further 800 to earthquake
strengthening
and for x and axis improvements no
reference was made there to the original
1.7
million commitment made in 2018
and thank you mr scout for raising that
it was reported in the paper
but it is not recorded in the minutes
the anderson house trust was formed in
2018
following a contracting
the venture southland now great south
called for expressions of interest to
occupy the house
we put forward a proposal in good faith
stating how we would operate
anderson house and this was followed
later with a staged
timeline and plan with key performance
indicators
that registration of interest has never
been acknowledged or responded to by
invercargill city council
the chief executive also told that
meeting of the u3a
that several tenants have been
considered but none have been successful
we have never been informed of other
registrations of interest
but we do know of a commercial interest
following a consultant's report on the
use of the ca
of anderson house with designs
which included a really expensive
upgrade
this plan had a figure to lease the
property so we went off
and went to a caterer and a restaurant
owner to get
those figures sorted and we were it was
found that those
that lease figure was not a viable
option for
any business to operate at that time so
that may have been what the chief
executive was referring to
councillors are the communities
governance directors of this
multi-million dollar business
and we as citizens have entrusted each
of you
to make decisions and see them carried
out
or given a very good reason publicly
while they're not
the oversight and follow-up is your
responsibility as our representatives
we do not see this happening based on
ours
and the public's just opinion and
first-hand experience of working with
council and staff to get anderson house
open thank you thank you can i
just correct a small point and the
council's unanimous vote was to make the
building weather tight
okay oh well not not a full upgrade bob
we don't control that um can i can i ask
thanks for the submission marion can i
ask
for us to be able to go beyond
weathertight and go to an upgrade we
would first need to know what the
purpose
of of the building is would you accept
that as as
reasonable accept that um to the best of
your knowledge has a purpose
been identified that we're not aware of
uh we have identified several purposes
and and issued that kpi to the
manager of parks and recreation at that
time and it should be available in your
records
but those purposes have not been adopted
by no council
no they haven't been made made or
considered by council but i
mr mcguire is running a workshop
tomorrow
about a possibility of events and
and um things happening in the yeah i
understand and appreciate that's still a
work in progress
thank you councillors it's open for
questions councillor pottinger
right um the
the thing that we did pass about weather
tightening
uh structural strengthening the roof and
doing that up
that keeps it original with the ability
to open the door still the same toilet
so
the next step if it was to be used as a
venue
degree do you agree or what are your
comments on what it need
better bathrooms toilets wheelchair
accessibility
better kitchen catering because
that is that's another step and i just
wonder if that's what
was agreed to in the 2018 long-term plan
which you seem to enjoy making long-term
plans
this is the second one in three years no
no i'm just asking the question now
sorry
okay uh it says here that there was a
commitment to
put a lift in and toilets and make it
accessible to the public
yeah i was aware of that uh that dream
thing and the
lift was on the outside and everything
and
yeah yep so that obviously never went
through
so with the current situation and
keeping the building
original to the historic places trust
you know which i think it must be
do you think um major alterations inside
are warranted
to to to keep up with code
uh well which would have to be you
wouldn't know what what the
code requires yeah there's major right
up with the code
but um yeah i'm aware that
there is also criteria around the
heritage status of the building which
i'm aware of
uh but yes um i don't know that there
would need to be structural
alterations no it's not the structural
side it's it's putting in the toilets
toilets and stuff wheelchairs it's a
commitment for
every public building is it not so there
would be you would expect
council for its next step to be that
commitment yeah
i would hope that that's been factored
into a budget and that
i imagine what do you expect that
commitment to be
tied in with guidance on usage
rather than just doing it but again i
mean
usage is um as how long as a piece of
string i mean
if if chicken thing we're a voluntary
group
we need to raise money to and probably
appoint an advanced manager should we
be able to take the building over but
the reality is
um down the track 10 years time you know
we may not be there there may be another
group or it may morph into something
else so
you have to future-proof these things
could i just
add that it's very difficult to see much
enthusiasm
in terms of future use of a building
that's barely weather tight
and in need of earthquake strengthening
and no
nothing physical happening so it's very
hard to develop much enthusiasm for a
project
when you can't quantify how long it's
going to be before you can kick it off
that's right
exactly or what shape you're going to
have finished to work with
okay thank you again it's a chicken and
egg situation mary and i'm sure with
your long experience in local government
you're aware that
long-term plans are an obligation that
we have to go through every three years
i don't think i'd stick to every three
years every three years we have to
produce a 10-year plan
30 years for infrastructure it's a
thrilling thing
i can see your enjoyment actually it's
been a pretty good two days so far
counselors any further questions
if not look we appreciate the the
submission and
and understand the position that that uh
that you're in and and thank you for
coming along this afternoon thank you
marcus welcome along
good uh your worship counsellors and
council staff
um marcus roy takawinga i'm i'm here to
speak
on behalf of the south and about club
submission and all the other associated
submissions that were received
in support of that submission thanks max
could you just drag that microphone over
a little bit
cool thank you there you go um our
submission does not provide input on the
major topics consulted on for this ltp
rather it focuses solely on the parks
and reserve activity
and in consideration of the time and i
don't envy the position of the
counselors in the afternoon slot
just after lunch so i appreciate the uh
the hard work you're doing and
i appreciate it it's a bit hard to keep
on track
um i want to make sure i spend the time
wisely and
for your ease the front page of the
submission outlines the key points which
i really want to draw to your attention
i don't
expect you to read the whole document
but if you can hold it on those front
key points it's the key message um
effectively i want to speak to three key
components of that um in my few minutes
i've got with you
first point is people so people are one
of the key reasons the
province of southland is a great place
to live and do business and having a
city with heart is important
however people are the lifeblood
providing vibrancy to our spaces
places businesses and events the culture
the support the comfort
our connection and our future open
spaces play
a vital role for enabling people to be
mobile feel connected to nature
recreate play and create opportunities
queen's park
there's no doubt a jewel in the of
invercargill and highly used by the
community
however many other places and spaces
within the icc jurisdiction are
underutilized
run down and undervalued
second key point um motu pahou bluff
and the 88 page at parks and reserve's
activity management plan bluff
was mentioned specifically four times um
as outlined in the south and regional
tourism strategy and the bluff master
plan
bluff's got a lot of potential to be a
significant draw card for the region
and the mountain bike club considered
that some targeted
support and specific projects would
unlock wind rate wide ranging
opportunities for the people of bluff
and invercargill third key point
um opportunity south america club has
developed a mountain bike master plan
which
facilitate all four of the local
government well-beings while utilizing
the cargo city council reserve land on
bluff hill
and we're keen for your support to
establish
a regional mountain biking destination
which will deliver the following
benefits for the community new low
carbon tourism activity for bluff
drawing visitors from around otago and
southland to ride
business opportunities associated with
mountain biking tourism bike hire bike
shops coaching
uplift shuttle services hospitality
industries
associated with food beverages
accommodation providers recreational
health benefits for local residents
having a well-designed and developed
facility on their doorstep
ecological enhancement supporting the
bluff hill multiple hearing
environmental trust with the great work
that they're doing
to restore the muri of motupahu by
removing wilding pine trees establishing
ecological corridors
peace trapping corridors and planting
natives along the new mountain bike
track
establishing new walking tracks from the
main street near the businesses up to
the top of the hill so you could have
connectivity from the businesses up and
over and round and back
and also linking mountain bike trails
with the
bluff of the cargo cycleway that's been
created at the moment
ebb and historic interpretational
signage showcasing bluff in the history
of the hill
and also hold annual or bi-annual
national level events drawing national
visitors and potentially international
visitors to town
so attached mounted bike master plan
which is attached to the submission
with your support will enable cultural
economic social and environmental
opportunities for the people of bluff
and invercargill who will continue to be
the lifeblood of our province
and accordingly what we're seeking in
the support and the submission here is
to bring some of the allocated funding
for that
activity forward um to enable us to
unlock that potential sooner
and derive benefits sooner than
anticipated so
those are the the key points i wanted to
talk to but i appreciate that there may
be
some questions on the submission
thanks marcus um can i kick off with one
having been down there to provide
shuttle services myself i was astounded
at the
the numbers that were on the trails do
you have any idea how many
how many people are making use of the
the trails
we don't cross a weekend effectively we
haven't got a track counter
numbers or volumes so the mountain bike
club has currently about 400 members of
active
paying memberships but we know that
there's thousands of people that use the
mountain bike tracks city point and
bluff
that are not members are visitors to
southland
and don't contribute financially to the
club and i guess as part of the club
we see ourselves as providing our
facilities for the community
but we're doing that off our own takings
and our own
financial benefit from races and events
and
unfortunately we haven't got the
capacity to undertake
a project of this manner with the way
we've been doing it in the past so we
need to change our game
and seek funding to actually do some
more work
thank you councillors open for questions
councillor lush
yeah marcus um what the proposal for the
bike path from
ocean beach if you've got a proposal
there for ocean beach around the back of
the hill
is it on private land yes so we have had
discussions with the private landowner
that was previously a farm and they are
keen to facilitate
um mountain biking tracks on their
private land
um this proposal that we're seeking to
solely talks to
initial tracks within the department of
conservation estate
that is right on the top of the hill and
also the indica city council reserve
land
long term the mountain bike club think
that it'll be great to establish a
coastal cycle trail to a maui
around the back beaches which would be a
great you know one day ride
that would link to bluff and maui but
that is not part of this initial
proposal but it's something futuristic
that
given sufficient time down the pat down
the track that it could be an
opportunity worth investigating
energy shared writing between sterling
point
and the lookout is that the way that we
complete that is that something you've
gotten
you've thought of uh not specifically
we've had initial discussions but that
links in with the
te oro trail and some of the department
of conservation estate too so there's a
few processes that would link in but
there is some water races on the
eastern side of the hill that lincoln
with existing reservoirs that could
provide good
tracks that will stick to a general good
grade elevation
around the front side of of bluff hill
okay
to get the sterling point in back as
well
thank you and the questions counselors
if not thank you not only for your
submission but the the work that you're
doing
in the area to facilitate an activity
that seems to be
uh growing in stature and engagement and
also for taking the time to come along
and speak to your submission this
afternoon we appreciate it
thanks very much
lillian
welcome along thank you
my submission on behalf of the saint
paul's harrion athletic club
is on the sorry park grandstand renewal
a st paul's harrier and emmitt's
athletic club submit the support of
athletic southland's request that the
proposed demolish
and replacement of the grandstand at
sorry park has been paying
for 12 months and that the 1.5 million
budget for the work remains allocated
and held over for
that period saint paul's acknowledges
that the existing grandstand has been
assessed as having structural issues
that propose
safety risks to users the demolish
of the grandstand presents the athletic
community with a new
unique opportunity to rethink the
traditional configuration
and use of facilities the saint paul's
is committed to doing
in partnership with other users if the
council agrees
to defer making a decision about the
grandstand
until there has been time to identify
funding partners
development of appropriate collaborative
strategy approach
supported by businesses case state bulls
intends to play its part in forming a
plan
which delivers the outcome identified at
the southland
regional space and places strategy
st paul's may be sacrificing much in the
process
but are willing to work cooperatively to
deliver the best result for the wider
athletic community
and other users not only now but in the
future
proposed replacement grandstand is too
small
saint paul's is concerned the current
grandstand proposes
a seating of two to three hundred
spectators and competitors
as being short-sighted the ottoman
report
group used christchurch in timaru as
their examples
as we all know weather is very
changeable down here
if we take our competitive months where
major athletic meetings could be held
from december to april
christchurch on an average has 6.2 days
of rainfall per month
timaru has 6.7 days rainfall
invercargill has 10.4 days rainfall per
month
as we are more likely to need to use the
grandstand more often
than will will well-being of
um for the well-being of our athletic
community
i was in christchurch in april this year
when the south island secondary school
athletic track and field champs were
held
the weather suddenly turned from for the
worst
with strong winds and rain there was
only standing room available in the
grandstand for shelter
so many people that could left the venue
instead of supporting their teams
st paul's is disappointed that we had no
opportunity to have import into
expressing our views
before it went to the sorry part future
development business case
that was presented to you in february
this year
the resulting uncertainty and lack of
information
had been frustrating south and athletics
community is planning
for growth and innovation st paul's urge
councils to press the
pause button to give us give us all
concerned
the time to develop a grandstand that is
multi-user for not only athletics
football but future endeavors at sorry
park
thank you thank you for your submission
um just a quick question with something
you were talking about there with the
the
surrey park plan did the surrey park
users group not consult with you at all
uh we had one speaker there but that was
it was it
did they not consult with the user
groups uh yeah they were
present okay uh
speakers yesterday talked about um
orienting the new grandstand a little
further down the track
um how does that sit with the way the
weather comes is that
and from some paul's perspective a good
move
well if they move the grandstand more
towards the finish line
that's where saint paul's is
how much use do you make of your rooms
how how heavily are they used sorry
uh they are used quite a lot by
different um not only
by athletics the schools use them and
hire them out
uh we've had netball teams that have had
tournament at the stadium use it
softball teams use it so it's reasonably
widely used
okay councillors counselor rabbit um i
just
have to leave for a couple of minutes oh
absolutely
councillor scout thank um
thanks elaine just a couple of other
submitters talked about the car parking
accessibility around that area
given the opportunity of um taking a
pause button
do you see as others did perhaps there
may be some red redevelopment around
that to get better access
um into that area there was discussion
around i think coming off tay street
if you've got any thoughts around that
uh i don't have a
problem with that we've just got to make
sure that
we don't lose out basically would it be
a desire for you to
increase that situation
going forward if we could if we could
get some increased parking around that
area
uh yeah as long as it wasn't parallel we
all good yep
cool thank you thank you
further questions counselors
if not thank you very much for coming
along this afternoon we appreciate it
craig welcome back
thank you for hearing me so i am
presenting this afternoon on ensign
house and uh
and i know you've already heard one
submission on that uh we've also
in our written submissions i set it out
in bullet point
form to try and be pithy and to the
point and
so hopefully you've had the opportunity
to have a look at that
the uh in the media recently we've seen
two articles on
anderson house and uh
i was wondering about that so i rang the
southern times and i said how is it
these articles on anderson house just
seem to keep popping up out of the
woodwork now and again and
and uh the person i spoke to at the
southern time says well
you know we can't reveal sources to you
but i can tell you have quite a
sophisticated database
and the database looks back at articles
we've previously written
and it brings them up again and says is
this still relevant do you want to
publish something on this again and
southern times is very sophisticated all
we need to do is
change dates and do a little tweaking of
a name here and there
and push republish and hey presto in one
minute flat we've got a new article on
anderson house
and he said we know nothing much happens
with anderson at us so
it's a great thing to pop up every now
and again and we run the story and
everybody's happy in fact southern times
went on to tell me
you might come as news to you that their
database is so sophisticated it can
predict
the future it's a little bit like that
movie back to the future you know where
you see
photos change and what events happen
they said
our database can also do that so really
so what happens if you punch in anderson
house 2031
to time with this annual plan what
happens
say well i mean again i'm a bit nervous
about this but i said look i'll send you
the article
that pops up so he sent me the article
through
so i'll quote it says council undertakes
to have anderson park homestead reopened
to the public next year this of course
is in the year 2031.
might even have to buy glasses on to
read this
18 years since the council closed
anderson park at a council
council infrastructure committee meeting
yesterday the green light was given for
council staff
to draw up in terms of reference for a
project manager to be appointed to
manage the earthquake strengthening and
related maintenance work at anderson
house
while this had previously been approved
as early as the 2018-28 ltp and
subsequent ltps
and the latest 2031-34 ltp
council i believe they're now in firm
grounds to declare that work on the work
will commence with a view to having sir
robert anderson's former home
being open to the public again next year
mayor blank blank it wouldn't give me
that information
okay thanks to former mayor pottinger
for getting matters to this point
mayor blank blank noted that
unfortunately mr pottinger could not be
at the meeting
after his zimmer frame legs became stuck
in a pothole in his non-existent
pathway outside his morris bush
residents
anderson house trust representatives
were astonished and displayed at the
news
trust chair crane mcallister was
astonished mayor pottinger could not
recall morris which has no footpaths
and despite yet again that the council
could not recall having approved this
work in the previous four
ltps mr mccounster said on behalf of the
residents of invercargill the trust
remains disappointed the only visible
thing council have managed to do against
the park in all these years
was to spend two hundred thousand
dollars relocating the don street
umbrella to anderson park
developing the duck pond as an
ecological heritage site in an av
ivarian retirement village ends
that's my attempted humor but the point
being that we will spend on this
project continuously without really
making any firm
progress towards getting it to where we
want it to go
and so to come to my more formal
submission points uh to reiterate the
point that marion made
on the 1.7 million approved in the
2018-28
long-term plan uh the current figure now
at 1.2 million that's fine and we
appreciate councils doing work in the
background
but there is so much more to be done on
that house than just getting it
strengthened
and just doing some maintenance work to
improve its weather tightness
opening the door when you open the door
the house is quite tired inside and
there's an awful lot of
restoration type work to bring it up to
an acceptable
venue that people would enjoy visiting
so i mean again it seems to be a 500 500
000 discrepancy
that has evaporated on us and
we would like to sort of perhaps
understand a bit more about them
and invocad was 2018 2028 ltp
under some obscure heading called
monitoring of community outcomes
and then under another subheading the
community outcomes are
has a piece that says to preserve
it's and i presume it's as
invercargill's character
we will know success when invercargill
is celebrated for preserving its
heritage character well
where does anderson park house sit when
we're talking about preserving
invercargill's character i would have
thought that's a premier
uh example of the character of
invercargill it just sits there very
idle has done for seven years and seems
to be rotting away
and that's to say we know success when
it's celebrated preserving well
i'm not sure that we can celebrate
preserving anderson house at this point
in time here
the other thing with anderson house that
doesn't often get made raised is that
the farapuni
so the forupone has bora in it some
attempts were made earlier on to get rid
of the borah but the stillboro there and
it comes back through
and the panels that were carved on that
varapini by a very well regarded carver
i don't know if they're at risk of borer
but i mean again it's something that
needs to be attended to him but
something does
doesn't need to wait on the work on the
house it can be carried out and quite
independently
of the work on on the house
2021 31 ltp states council will make
improvements to make the building safe
and enable the building to reopen to the
public in 2021
well i think that's probably a bit
optimistic
but also even when the building is
reopened to the public the question is
what will happen to the public in what
way
and in this regard i sort of found that
the roadmap to my renewal
wasn't particularly a masterpiece of
vision when it came to describing well
what are we going to do when we open the
door
and we can all talk about what we get
uses we're going to have for it but we
have to
when we open the door to the public
we've got to then use it for something
and at the moment
it's just not possible really to use it
for anybody there's only two toilets
downstairs
the upstairs rooms are full of old art
gallery storage equipment
the upstairs toilet facilities in the
old
caretakers flat and that too is a circa
1970s it's all
the old you might recall that green
ceramic stuff it's pretty tired
it all needs quite a bit of work and
bringing it up to speed
so and i i just made the point that it's
a bit disappointing that the
long-term plan didn't go on to sort of
say look we need we know we need to do
some stuff
and here's what we're going to do and
here's how we're going to budget it i
think the point marion raised is well
we don't want to just then get the door
open and then we're going to have
another round of discussions
and fundraising for yet again
and while yet again the door remains
closed i mean the
um trust ran a family fun day at
anastasia park
recently we had circa 700 people there
was a fabulous day
i ran the council said can we open a
window door to plug a plug-in so the sit
music people can have electricity
and there was horror you can't plug a
plug-in
you might blow a fuse well if we can't
plug a plug-in now
can we plug a plug-in when we open the
door if we can't can we start
work on this now so we understand and
get it down to now
why do we keep waiting it's almost like
there's a stage
process to nowhere on this thing
uh the other point finally i want to
make on this is the ground so
you know the trust made a lot of
submissions on what we could do within
the grounds
perhaps we could have some wi-fi on the
grounds perhaps we could have some
coffee facilities in the ground
stuff that doesn't rely on the house
being open not hard to do
bring it into the 21st century for
visitors
well we still sort of haven't done
anything um
and again i guess it gets a little bit
uh disappointing when
doing status quo is nothing so my point
is don't let this council be the one
that forms the basis of the above
headlines in 2031. what we want are
headlines
such as anderson park celebrates 100th
wedding anniversary at the parks that's
reopened
ilt hold their agm at anderson park
anderson park voted new zealand's top
wedding venue for three years running
bringing an estimated 30 million dollars
into the city
prime minister of new zealand the right
honourable penny simmons
host key australian minister dan park
pottinger trips over zimmer frame
anderson park car park on way to his own
50th wedding anniversary
the anderson house trust urges the
council to grasp the opportunity to now
to restore and develop anderson park and
in context to take the trust concerns on
board
and confirm the full allocation of funds
appropriated in the 2028
so 2018 2028 ltp forget in the building
including the interior
fit for purpose as a function and events
center that all invercargill residents
can be proud of
thanks craig can i ask you a similar
question thanks for the entertainment as
well can i ask you a similar question
um that i put to the previous speakers
and that
if we spend money to make sure the
building is is weather tight in this
instance
should is it wise for us to spend more
money
on the interior until we've determined
what the use is
but i think the uses are fairly well
understood
uh for example does the obvious one
weddings
but this conference is hiring it out for
other functions such as
people's wedding anniversaries or
organizations might want to hire to host
a
to have a a a a function for their firm
there's plenty of uses there but all of
those uses
the interior is going to have to be up
to a similar standard
regardless of whatever use goes on in
there we're going to have to have
at least some functioning toilets
caterers are going to have somewhere to
put food
and and maybe keep it warm and chill
things
there's nothing there now the kitchen's
just gutted and gone
so we just do need to think about it
what i'm trying to say now rather than
leave it till we get the door open and
then we go well now what
um yeah because otherwise we could sit
around another three or four years
because this sort of my point
i'm trying to make here is that we don't
want to be another 10 years down the
track and still
and i don't want you to be the council
that lets us get to that stage
where we're still trying to talk about
what we're going to do in it
thanks craig councillor zimmer frame
poppinger
i'm looking forward to that um
craig um walking inside anderson house
it's um after being in the in the
grounds and looking at it
and it's splenda it's actually
incredibly underwhelming
it's just underwhelming yeah you walk in
there and
it's a whole lot of small rooms a lot of
small rooms and the
i remember uh can we get to the question
because we are tight on time
okay we've run the second bell will you
would you
be prepared to sort of cut the place to
make it usable as a venue because
i don't believe it is usable downstairs
as is
upstairs it will need consideration
about perhaps okay but
i'm just trying to understand the
question is
how would it function as a wedding venue
or where it's just too small
it's just not practical right so there
are provision that we're
putting us for the grounds for marquis
sites and the like okay so that would
happen outside
yeah okay yeah councillor thank you
um craig i guess from what we've heard
and it's embarrassment to be honest
both the previous council the current
one but having passed what we have
passed so i find it incredibly
disappointing but moving forward let's
look forward
is the vision for you to you're asking
council on how to make it
take a leap of faith in the sense of
getting something done
yes the good part about that is
obviously you're fully aware of with
aaron and steve have worked really hard
on
twilight this is a question isn't it
council well it leads to the next
question
but i'll come back to time again
all right well okay um just you're
asking for a leap of faith enough for us
to get our backsides into gear and do
something
yes thank you yeah thank you thank you
councillor clark
i'll just have a last question without
any uh any other comment
after craig um it seemed in your
submission that you were talking about
basically two stages one was the
earthquake prone
remedial work and the water tightness of
the
spilling which is basically exterior but
then you were also saying
that you need some internal work done so
my question is
is it possible for council to do the
former
and leave the second phase to be done
at further discussion or are you saying
it should all be one package
well there's some work that could be
done now for example um
and the problem is that through the
infrastructure committee meeting with
signal to the public look work is going
to commence i think even the target
daily time said
commence immediately and yet nothing's
happening and it's right so for example
even just
some exterior cleaning sure some
exterior paint work could be done
we don't need to wait on the earthquake
strengthening to do some of this stuff
this is the point i'm trying to make
really one quick question just to
clarify
your remedial work that you're talking
about on the outside of the building
which is
water to making it watertight you'd need
to do that after you've done the
strengthening work wouldn't you
look maybe ideally but there's nothing
stopping us painting some of it or doing
some of the woodwork the windows are
starting to split and crack
why can't we go in there remove some of
those take them away repair them put
them back in
thank you thank you thank you mr
mcallister
mr swain
welcome along again sir
uh thank you for the opportunity to come
along and talk to you
um i've really just taken an overview of
your long-term plan to be quite honest
there are several areas of concern to me
and one is the sporting venues in
invercargill
and the other one is the question the
rates i'm the chairman of the
south and food bank so i deal with the a
lot of the other underprivileged
people who are feeling defensive quite a
bit about the rates
the thing about the sporting venues is
that the hub
of the is the cargo is a stadium
and nigel and his team were doing a
great job to induce people to come
and i thank you for that and the other
thing is that in that
area too there's the other grandstand
which the
athletic clubs and the soccer clubs have
been using for many years and don't do
as much now
i think it's the priority that that gets
done sooner
rather than later i see in the
review the other day that the hockey uh
sorry the soccer people and the
athletics may see it as an opportunity
to build their club rooms in it
as long as they come up with the money
for the club rooms i don't have a
problem with it
but i think the council needs to fire
ahead and get that grand stand up and
going as soon as possible in my humble
opinion
and of course the other grand stand is
the rugby park one well that's
an unusual kettle of fish to be quite
honest uh the park is only used for
rugby as
better careful than i know now at this
time
and the amount of gains we get there
unfortunately is about six to eight in
the season i think pete
without getting any representative games
so you then you've got to balance up do
you want a full grand stand
or do you downsize the grandstand and
that's an interesting question
i've been a seasoned ticket holder for
many many years and i've noticed now
that the
people are dropping off and the
grandstand is not full
never has been the last three to four
years that's probably the stag's fault
for not winning the games
but even so you know you've got to take
that on board when you're doing these
costings
so that's two priorities and i said that
last year and i was talking about the
other thing that
gripes you a wee bit is with tourism
which you're doing a great job with
getting people into the town
they have to have somewhere to go and
one of the ones that have closed down
because of the so-called earthquake risk
was anderson's
house the water tower and and
that's about it now i've lived in this
this city for over
just about 80 years and i can count on
my hand how many times you had an
earthquake
and how much damage is done in that time
it's been nothing
so we better be we've gotten a bit of a
false paradise with this earthquake
thing in my opinion
but i i do believe like the last
gentleman was saying if you could do
something to anderson he'll see like do
the outside
get to make it look like a the old house
it used to be
because i was reading an article after
one of the north north papers actually
and it said
it's great to go to anderson's park but
don't go too close to it
view it from a distance because you see
all the faults
but there's no reason as he said why why
don't you do the outside
waterproof it which leads me to another
question which the council
hasn't addressed in their long-term plan
what about the buildings down the end of
uh welcome to place
you own those and they're due to be
demolished because
because there's no way you're going to
repair those ones but you haven't got
that in
your long-term plan so that's the
the main thing that you've you seem to
put things
on and then you move them back and you
keep moving them back
and they don't get done so i encourage
you to stop that
attitude get stuck in and get the main
points done so we get the people back
into town
and the other thing i'm pleased to see
that you've agreed to the s
street upgrade i'm not sure what it is
but i just hope that
with the air street upgrade you limit
all the cars
and take them right out all together
because it would be an ideal precinct
like they have up in christchurch
where you can walk around without cars
coming through but i see in the earlier
plan they wanted to have cars
or about 12 or 20 cars come into it i'd
wipe all the cars out altogether
you may have done that already and the
other thing of course
don't cut the four lanes down in the
main streets
because invercargill is renowned for its
wide streets
and i can't see any sense in cutting
them down because you'll just end up
with a bottleneck at the
wall memorial on the corner so your bit
off to keep your
streets wide cut out your um street
press with your
best people and then we'll have a decent
city
so i can only like to say that thank god
we've got the ilt
the richardson group and sits on the
ground because they are the ones
that are actually moving the city so
it's now up to you people
to get up give it a shove and get it
going again
now as regards to the rates there's this
thing that i am gravity concerned about
i know you set your level at five
percent over the next say
10 years whatever it is we deal with
people who are struggling
it's right across the spectrum in vicar
you mightn't see it here but we go out
and visiting these people with the food
etc so it's a major problem out there
and if you keep increasing your rates by
five percent each year
which you're planning to they're not
going to cope that includes pensioners
beneficiaries and ordinary people it's
just going to get
out of kilter but i don't know how
you're going to overcome that one
because your budgets are pitched to a
point aren't they
in your long-term plan and if you don't
get that money come in and you're in
trouble
but you cannot keep putting the pressure
on the rate payers of invercargill
and the other one of course i think the
ratepayers of bluff have been a bit hard
done by they uh
wanting their their pool upgraded which
makes sense to me
and there's some i read their
submissions here the other day and i
think
they're right you know they bluff should
get that pool up and running for the
kids down there
and always want to learn to learn how to
swim
and the town itself is quite vibrant
because the the people are gorilla
i'll do an attitude down at bluff i'd
like to get the bluff always to fear
still anything else that comes along
they're all hooking behind it so we've
got to give consideration of looking at
how you're going to balance your rates
out now some people come back and say oh
you get a right rebate well that's true
you need a rates rebate
but the race rebate is not going to
cover the money that's going out all the
time
it's going to erode it so anyway i'd
just like to say you you're on the right
track
there's one or two things near tidied up
we have got a vibrant city coming up
with a
new precinct down here and the question
of the playground for the kids i don't
think it's required in invercargill
i know the one in christchurch i've seen
and it's it's a beautiful setup
but we haven't got the population to
warrant it and if you did do it we're
going to put it
it was suggested in the last time you
did our best street we do it down at the
old rsa bowling ground uh club grounds
but
it's not big enough for a decent
playground anyway so you've just got to
keep that in mind
but as i said wherever and said if we
just give it a nudge and get it up and
running again we'll be right
to thank you thank you very much mr
spain for your submission and thank you
for your mahi with the food bank as well
on behalf of our community we we
appreciate it council is open for
questions if there are any
i'll let you off this time you're
running out of time
thanks very much mr swan we appreciate
it thank you
no no mr butson
good timing sir
welcome along thank you uh we have your
submission and for the next 10 minutes
you have the floor please have a seat
thank you
your worship councillors i've come in a
personal capacity to you here today i
am a member of the south and rugby
referees association
and i don't know if it's always that
well known that our club room is at
rugby park so particular interest in
speaking to you about rugby park today
so preferred option as in my submission
love to see that go ahead
ideally i'd love to see that go ahead in
a more accelerated time frame but i
realize you have other constraints
upon you at the moment the
just from a few personal words about why
rugby park is so important to us
obviously having the clubhouse there is
a big asset to us
simply because refereeing as you could
probably imagine isn't always
necessarily an easy job
and the room that we retain there is
very important for
the development of younger referees the
education of all the referees
and establishing a consistency across
the association as well to make sure
that
when we're going out that the the rugby
clubs and the public that we're serving
actually has a level of referee that's
consistent from one week to the next and
you're not wondering what you're dealing
with on any particular weekend
so for me being a sort of a little bit
longer in the tooth now i'm getting a
wee bit slower on the paddock
just having the rooms there especially
for seeing the younger guys come into
a place that's been the home of south
and rugby for a long time
and certainly the referees association
has been established for
i think we're in our 127th year now
and the vast majority of that we have
had a presence at rugby park
so seeing those young guys come into the
club room looking over the pitch at
rugby park and
just you can you can see what effect it
has on them it's a great motivator
and for me it's been a unique one as
well because
having referees and four different
associations
to be able to actually go to your home
of rugby is
just an absolutely fantastic asset to
have
and it is a it just yeah
makes you feel really like you're part
of something and it's magnificent
feeling to have
and i think the other side of it is is
having that clubhouse there as well it's
a good
social outlet for us too
certainly from a refereeing point of
view i don't know whether anyone here
would relate to this or not but
sometimes when you've finished your job
on a saturday afternoon you come off the
pitch and no one's really talking to you
and you feel like you've done an
absolutely crap job
to be able to go back to a group that
has the same
the same backgrounds the same
experiences
as you especially and i speak for i know
i describe myself as long the teeth but
there's a couple of guys possibly longer
in the tooth than me at the association
to come back to be able to talk to those
guys about it who have been in the same
position before
just really helps you from a i suppose
from an emotional point of view but also
from a developmental point of view
and help you tackle those situations so
really the idea behind
me talking to you is i don't think
everyone realizes
that we have a presence at rugby park
what an important
important thing it is for us to have a
club room that we can belong to
and just in the context of i believe
that we provide a valuable service to
the
not just the invercargill public but the
south and public as a whole
for what we do at the weekends during
the winter because
it is a voluntary thing we're not being
paid for what we do
and most of us love it but there are
times when we don't
so i just wanted that to be part of the
consideration with
the development of rugby park that we're
a community group
we're working out of there we're doing
our best for the south and public
and we would support that well sorry i'm
saying we i'm talking probably for too
many of us but from my personal point of
view i'd really like to see
that development of rugby park go ahead
thanks adrian
i know there's at least one person at
the table who will understand the
scrutiny and criticism that comes
with adjudicating sports matches um
and we all know what it's like to be in
front of people and
subject to comment and criticism so we
appreciate where you're coming
from from the perspective of the
referees though do you have an opinion
on on on a desire from council to see
more user groups making use of the
facilities at rugby park
i can't speak for the association as a
whole um
my own personal point of view is
there's council involvement therefore
there's involvement from
the wider public of invercargill and
i think if it was going to be utilized
for other outdoor sports then
certainly that would be an avenue that
would have to be open
absolutely so that the whole public
could have access
and enjoy the the outdoor
um sports there thank you
counselors any other questions or
comments
your worship yes adrian um
at the moment there seems to be a lot of
diversification and rugby there
nines and sevens and women's rugby and
and do you think there's enough there to
stem the tide of
big 60 inch tv sitting at home on the
couch
in terms of you talking about people
going out and actually bums on seats
and go attending games you worship yes
i think when it's your team involved and
that
and we have seen that other venues there
is often other
items on the agenda and certainly
last year i know that they did run a
couple of things with the npc games such
as the
the blair vining game and the general
admissions i think
that side of things will have to be part
of it to entice people in
but for certainly people with uh love of
the game
and those associated with the team
there's
you're always going to get those ones
coming and i think we
probably see that at the smaller
clubhouses week in week out
about who's turning up and
the support that those teams are getting
so
my finishing statement on that would be
a cliche but you build it and they will
come
thanks adrian no further questions thank
you oh sorry councillor scott
thanks adrian you mentioned the culture
and how important the ground was
to obviously from the referee's
perspective and obviously
um trickling down um you're a broken
family at the moment would that be for
your comment in the sense of a home
well there isn't a home is that fair
the i suppose the big
danger for us is if we were to become
without a home
we struggle at the moment for retention
and recruitment
what effect that would have on us even
purely from
we've got quite a good setup now with
the meetings the education etc but if
that
focus was being pulled away from
developing our
referees into and we've got referees who
are
touch judging for or assistant
refereeing should i say for npc
level and some of those and we do have
ones who are being
actively looked at in terms of further
advancement within the system
it is one of those issues if we take our
eye off the ball in terms of that
core role of developing referees
to what are we going to do about where
we're going to meet
what sort of audio visual things are we
going to have etc
that would be very hard on us as an
association i was just trying to dive a
wee bit deeper in the sense of
the collective larger problem we've got
with rugby as it sits at the moment and
the facility
linking to the ltp but um
we've got it the high performance guys
we've got the admin guys we've got the
coaches
we've got the stags um all in different
parts
yes and disseminated in the city for one
of a better word and you guys are
another part of that
trying to flip it on its head how would
you feel as if we could if we found a
home
for the total group do they necessarily
have to be
at rugby park just thinking totally
outside the square
if we could put collectively the whole
group together
get the family back together regain the
culture under one roof
would that in your opinion
work without necessarily being at rugby
park
so to answer your question in two parts
the first point of having everyone
together under the one roof i think that
would be very helpful
purely it's going to make some person
people's roles a lot
easier in terms of access we find so
much especially with the refereeing
point of view
communication is such a huge part of the
game and for
coaches players referees
to have access to each other and
understand
what we're trying to achieve and make
sure that we are all singing off the
same hymn book
is vital to the game the second part
i'll probably just go back to the
written submission i put in i think the
the location as it is is a very good
location
because you've got the presence to the
cbd i mean
i've been out to some grounds where
you're walking an
hour to get out there and you're walking
an hour back to town which is just
from a social point of view is a
horrendous place to be and whereas here
you're
10 15 minutes into town it's great and i
think there's also an advantage of the
site you've got there is that it's
really only bordered by residential
properties on the south side
and everything else is essentially a lot
more
you're not having to worry about what
effects you're having on the
the residents there for an extent you've
got the swimming pool
the caledonian and then girls high and
then you've got the
uh the green belt i suppose i'll call it
to an out to your
western side so from the point of view
of it being there i
think it's a good area for it to be i
wouldn't like to see it moved further
away from the city
centre
thank you any further questions
councillors councillor lush
does the rugby league association south
and rugby league do they have a
referees room a facility they use are
you aware of that
i'm not aware of that i'm sorry i
couldn't couldn't speak to that
would there be synergies if those if
that code was brought into the
rugby stadium as well would that be
something that the referees could share
a facility like that
i think we'd be open to that happening
that i think oh sorry i say we
again i don't want to speak for the
entire association because i can't
for myself i think we'd be open to other
other
groups yeah being able to i'd probably
like to see
the perhaps if the room did belong to
one particular group
and other groups have access to it i
think that's just easier from
even like an equipment and care of
things point of view
having one group responsible for that
but certainly in terms of giving access
to it i couldn't see any issue with that
thank you mr and no further questions
thank you very much for your submission
adrian and for making along this
afternoon
thank you very much
stella and ella
just stella welcome back
[Music]
my name is stella o'connor i'm a lead
systems innovator for healthy families
invercargill
and i'm here today as a representative
for the muruhiku kai collective
thank you for the opportunity to be
heard and i hope you've all had some
good kai
since i saw you last because it's been a
long day for you all
a big bit closer cool so the mirahika
kai collective is made up of a number of
community groups who have formed around
the common vision
of enabling southlanders to have the
capability
to produce and access good food
so we thank the various invercargill
city council staff
from the parks and recreation and waste
net teams
that have contributed to these meetings
and we hope that the icc management
see the value in them continuing to
attend
this council has repeatedly shown a
commitment to building
a strong cohesive vibrant community
and we know that you all value the
importance of community well-being
while there are parts of our community
that are thriving
there are also pocket pockets where the
opposite
is a reality and feedback from these
communities and families
show that one of the major struggles is
access to quality nutritious food
this was also exacerbated by the onset
of covert 19 pandemic
i just want to ask you to remember back
to last year with the onset
of covert 19 there would have been a
point in time
when you would have experienced that
panicked feeling
that you might not have access to food
to feed your family
this feeling may have been fleeting for
you but for some of their families that
we talk to
this is a reality most days the pandemic
exposed
inequalities but it also revealed
solutions
and we know that more shocks and crisis
are coming we have the chance to build a
more secure sustainable resilient local
food system
one that is healthier and supports
people more fairly
we're here to see the curio about how
together we can support a regenerative
local food system
that is prepared in times of natural
disasters climate change
supports self-sustainability and the
need to provide adequate
adequately for our communities
so we ask invercargill city council as
we've also asked the southland district
council and we'll ask the goal district
council as well
to lead in this space and help co-design
and adopt a mirahaku food resilience
strategic plan
this could be used by departments across
councils to inform and support their
current
and identify future work programs and
activities relating to food security
and food sovereignty there are various
actions that we've tabled that the
invercargill city council can support
and promote alongside the community to
reduce barriers so that our local food
producers
are supported more of our community are
growing
their own produce and our most
vulnerable
can have access to good food so now is
the time to commit
and include food resilience while we're
looking at our long-term planning
so that our region will have thriving
social
economic and physical environments
providing healthy affordable and locally
grown food for all people
thank you thanks stella
um what sort of financial investment are
you suggesting
would be involved from council
so we've we've tabled sort of some
short-term and long-term
um ideas as well as well as our own
as the mirahaku kai collective but
initially we're looking um i guess
for your policy people to come on board
and look at
uh where they have the food system and
in your
in your strategies in your councils
and how you can put everyone from parks
roading can put that lens across the
work that they do
so in the initial instance and you've
got your
short medium and long-term plan it's a
it's a staff resource
existing staff resource you wanting
access to okay thank you
councillors councillor pottinger thank
you i'm just trying to
understand what we can do actually i
mean when you talk about
parks reserves roading
um we talk about places to grow food are
we talking about
what's transportation of it or what is
it
well it could be anything like that we
had a really good example in the last
couple of weeks
where um park's team
said to us that they've grown uglies in
the winter garden
and which is great edible edible
edible harvest but how do we get that
out to the community so they contacted
the
kai collective who are able to get it
out
through self alive so it's about
starting that conversation that if you
are going to provide
edible plantings how do we what is the
understanding of how the community can
access it wouldn't it be more logical
say that you have the whole invercargill
pulling mcaugiel people probably grow
the ones that do grow
their own you know potatoes and
vegetables
have excess and wouldn't that be a great
place to start
first and get them to sort of say hey
you know we're not going to use all
these potatoes imagine chucking the
potatoes in the compost tea but terrible
you know when they can go you know and
that's where i i'm just
have you thought about that yeah
absolutely and that's where we're asking
council to come on board and lead in
this space as well and help us
so i talk to people every day that
actually
don't know where to start with gardening
so it could be that
your comms people have something on your
website
around the conditions for gardening in
southland they're quite peculiar for
southland compared to the rest of the
country so it's about being part of that
conversation with us
and using your leadership to amplify
and encourage everyone else to be part
of it
those sharing platforms are a good idea
though because you know
personally my garden has everything come
online at once
counselors any other questions
if not thank you stella for your
submission and
and nice to see you back again this
afternoon thank you
mr hodginson's at the back so you'll be
interested to know that counselors have
had a copy of your presentation
delivered to their ipads this afternoon
so it's it's
they have that full document right now
you're a veteran um and now you've got
the safety of a table and a seat thank
you very much once again
uh for your submission for coming along
this afternoon
are you familiar with the process the
floor is yours yes i think i'll be
familiar with the process and less
nervous
can you just bring the microphone up
please
um anyway i'm i'm basically here just to
submit
that the priority is the museum
development um
and the cbd um on the museum
issue i mean it's it's there's no
argument that this
is is the priority and the cost to the
community
of its closure is really high it's gone
on for a long long time
and there's a lot of passion i just want
to say like in surveying people
the questions are very simple aren't
they they don't always get the detail of
feelings so anyways
it serves the community universally and
my submission is that i'm wondering
if it can be achieved by starting afresh
by undertaking a cost-effective new
build on the tennis courts
adjacent to the museum i think
the sentiment is that rate payers want
a museum passionately at the park i
think the focus
on the pyramid is wrong like the
questions are too simple that the
passion is for the museum
cited at the park and for timeliness
and cost effectiveness and what concerns
me about the current plan
is its complexity of timing in terms of
moving contents out
but its complexity in terms of
complexity and risk
and cost associated with refurbishing
this building and it i actually would
acknowledge mr harper has his and
actually in his submission
like as a ratepayer i'm reading that the
cost of rebuilding
our museum refurnishing the existing one
is 10 000
per square meter where which is twice
the cost of starting
from scratch now that's huge and likely
the rebuild the current option is going
to run into problems and
and um cost run overs i think that's
just so startling to ratepayers the
difference
in the cost per square metre that that's
relevant to
really look at this closely again so
i've made a whole list of benefits
if you were to rebuild on the tennis
court sites it just seems sequentially
logical and timing
you can start straight away it delivers
it's timeliness that's important
and it eliminates the cost of having to
take stuff out and back and again
it eliminates your funding of the
temporary museum
it just removes risk and then you can
ring fence the problem
of the old museum for later it's storing
the contents that's a problem but it can
be
just put parked aside and dealt with
separately that's that's i'm thinking
there's a whole these
these topics should be explored and i'm
waffling and you'll have to read my
submission
um sorry and then the other things rugby
park
and i'm i felt angry because i'm like
how does that get there in my timeline
for 2023 and anderson's park has gone on
for seven years
and has talked about being delayed how
does it and with all respect to rugby
we're just talking the intricacies of
one
sports interest one recreational
interest one part of our community
how does that get 9. 9.4 million that's
a lot
in art galleries talked about at 17.
there's so much money
com it's just huge how does that get in
there and
how is there so much conversation about
it relative to these other bulls in the
ear
that have been in stasis for years right
so we've got over air
and i think ratepayers may feel that
quite strongly
that not to do the small things you
the big issues need dealt with rugby
park
the questions the survey says do you
want four
nine point four or four point nine
or four point nine well if you don't go
for 10 because you don't get it you'll
get 4.9
um i think there's a lot of issues here
that it's never going to be
a multi-use venue that's been talked
up and rodney tribe and his submission
has actually said that the proposal
to spend money on rugby party is huge
results
in an annual funding of five hundred and
fifty thousand dollars we have two
existing sports complexes
which also have annual funding like can
we afford this as a city of twenty four
thousand ratepayers
it's like so rodney trouble writes a
level of ratepayer funding is simply not
acceptable
as regardless of what talk there is
about additional use
which is largely for rugby the community
as a whole are never going to see any
meaningful increase in use
or actual return on the funds to justify
the ongoing spending
he's got the figures in the report and
he's
got the details that this projected
events it's just not going to stack up
simply put the numbers do not stack up
so i have read mr clarke's original
ideas talking about surrey park
and as a rate payer i don't have the
knowledge but i'm thinking
we have two existing sports ground in
vicinity
the proximal and that's where our
investment should be i think that's a
better formula
i'm not sure yeah that is the better
formula
um where invercargill city council and
rate pass are not in a financial
position to undertake
maintenance improvements at rugby park
oh by the way
40 where's my details 45
of submitters on rugby park said that it
should be
solely maintenance or not at all if you
lump those two groups together that's 45
said only what you need to do
or not at all and the summary of 55
percent
saying oh yes but i actually went
through and
33 submissions at least because i
couldn't do so much
that's nine percent of submitters they
only said
spend spin 9.4 and rub apart they did
not submit on priorities and say
if we do this what do you think that we
might not be able to do an art gallery
they just said hey it's been 9.4 that's
nine percent of those submissions are
just it's real simple it's rugby
move it up says about quite a number of
those
and um anyways
the spending of this five to ten million
on the specific use asset compromises
the pool of funds available for other
infrastructure um
it's not anyways i'm sorry it's not
income generating and is a liability
disproportionate
to its ability to produce future income
um we have to remember how much has been
spent in the past
which is i've come up from published
sources of eight million dollars of
public money
do we want to keep blogging a dig horse
i have written
or what do we want and expect from
direct rate pay benefit
um there are plenty of champions from
rugby
who can ensure a good outcome
if we were to use existing sports
assets um
anyways
um yeah
it's just duplicitous and
it's wrong compared to all these other
balls in the air
thanks louise uh as always your
submissions are well considered
and uh we also appreciate how long
you've spent going through
the other submissions as well and and
cross referencing them
um you know that that's a fair amount of
time and we appreciate you your
passion and engagement for that
councillors it's open for questions
councillor pottinger
thank you louise hi again um
january 15 sorry january 2015
council made the decision uh split vote
5'4 to purchase rugby park
um do you think that councils do you
think
first question do you think it was a
great decision and the second question
is do you think council should actually
do
uh one of those business plans or one of
those future
cost predictive things like we're facing
now that we bought that in 15
now we're facing the expenses so
um yeah do you think council should be a
bit more prudent
i think absolutely be print i think any
spending should be deferred i think the
ownership needs to be reviewed i think
nobby clark's ideas
of combine if that's appropriate to use
existing assets and look and actually
look at another use for rugby park um
but absolutely there's got to be
a plan now looking at its future use and
it has been talked up
it's it's but but even if even if some
figures can be tweaked about events
it's still you've got three sports
stadia in
a city of a small size
um but yes i think it needs to be fully
reassessed and it
and i would say the decision to buy it
was a very
was an unfortunate one at the time
like people are vocal and passionate a
smaller section of community
that it was talked up but any
potential for use was talked up and any
potential for risks of maintenance
were unknown and unexpressed and i feel
it was
i think it was a swing vote and i think
it was swayed on emotion
and not prudent purchase thank you
thank you councillor amundsen
thanks chair um i'm interested in your
thoughts on the museum
and here you've said that it might be
cheaper to build a new one
if it wasn't going to be cheaper to
build a new one would you still be in
favor of a new build
over retrofitting the existing pyramids
um i ca um i can't see how it can be of
the same cost or cheaper
if the footprint of building is
wayne harper has got published figures
there
um from his uh from um
that must be qb qv cost builders values
so i can't say it could be cheaper but
actually i see it as
as i think it's a bit of unknown how
it's all going to work if this plan
happens like it would be sequentially
logical i think
not just on the building footprint but
the costs of
um how do you do this take out
everything that's there
and and have to phys labor and the cost
of storing it
to actually have an empty museum to
refurbish
there's actually all those peripheral as
well as the construction cost there's
all these peripheral costs
of removal and storage so that i feel if
someone yeah and i think if this was
scoped or a seat if they knew but
if a new build was assessed there would
be all these additional adv
cost saving advantages that's what i
feel that will be logical
and within and known timely
you can start you can actually start
straight away because how long's it's
going to take to
remove those contents it's not a small
task
and it removes risk of
the unknown things you're going to find
in that museum
[Music]
that that needed unexpected to fix
and and plus um the risk of yeah the
risk of cost
overruns and risk of delays i think and
that may be
just as uh
that's that's huge delay is hugely
and probably unacceptable like people
are quite
yeah i think council can deliver can can
can deliver i just yeah a council can
deliver to rate payers
all those things timely and
if it's equal i can't see that it's
going to be dearer
[Music]
thank you final question to councillor
clarke yeah thank you chair um
louise um just turning that last
question around a little bit further
if we had only 50 million
to a portion to a current fit out
and re-strengthen um as opposed to some
suggestion that a new one could cost 70
or 80 million dollars
which is some previous estimates we've
had what would your view be on if we
didn't have the museum a new museum
as big as the current one given that the
current one's got quite a bit of storage
in it
sorry can you just say the first part
again
if instead of saying comparing like you
the previous question with the 50
million for refurbishment well we've got
we
we've said in the ltp that the overall
cost
not just the city's cost will be about
50 million dollars to strengthen
and redesign the museum and and we know
historically that a new build of a
similar size
would be about 70 80 million dollars
plus
what i'm suggesting is what your view
would be if we
built one for 50 million and accepted
that it was actually
smaller in size than the current one
given that we would know the storage
that's right so i yes i could live with
it i think
i think it's about the effect of use of
money isn't it for the for the
square meters for cost actually that is
now
okay that's now confusing me that the
footprint is bigger
but i think it's about the cost per
square meter and what you're getting for
that money and
the timeliness and the cost
effectiveness some of the smaller
museums i've seen have had
oh they're more flexibility internally
yes last question for you i guess is
given that we might use that as an
option to consider a smaller museum but
that could fit within the budget
where's the best location for it i i
feel
rather than speak for myself which is
the part i think the public
are saying the park and that that it's
not
it's for social reasons for recreational
reasons
it's it's emotional reason that reasons
that people like
link the park in the museum but it is
it is connecting for the amenity that
people go there they flow out into the
park the elderly
fathers with their children
it's i think that's that's the sentiment
of the community and that's what's been
submitted to council in the past
um yeah i think that would be a big
turn around
not deliver on time and people grumpy
now that if it went to the cbd
it doesn't it does perhaps from a
business point of view it's been talked
all that links but that but it's
actually a rate payer amenity
on many many fronts and that's desired
at the park
this is what i'm picking up not speaking
of myself okay
thank you thanks louise appreciate your
answers to the questions and your
submission thank you very much for
coming along
uh rick rick zwan on behalf of forrest
and bird now councillors
uh his submission is actually on page
1286
of board books so if you use the swipe
bar down the bottom
one two eight six so the parts work
welcome along wreck we've got ten
minutes um
you can use the whole 10 minutes if you
want or you can leave room for questions
or choices you're all right but thank
you for your submission and for making
yourself available
uh kyoto koto it's good to be here my
name is rexwan so i'm the regional
conservation manager for forest and bird
uh relatively new to the role started
this year
covering otago and southland as well
um so yeah it's a pleasure to be here
boston bird
has a long history uh in the city this
southland branch has been around for a
while and it's quite an active branch
a lot of members involved out in the
community
looking after nature restoring places
ensuring that our real
special species are looked after and
inadequately protected
and i think that really helps to enhance
uh
enhance the well-being of the wider
community as well
a lot of people as you know choose to
live here and
because of the accessibility of the
wonderful
outdoor areas that we've got around this
around the city
and the nature that is within the city
as well in spectacular coastlines and
rivers and mountains it's a it's a
wonderful part of the country to live in
so the the core of our submission is
to try and encourage the council to
recognize the importance
of nature broadly and to the city
specifically
uh and recognizing that we are living in
a dual biodiversity crisis
and climate crisis and is a huge
imperative to do all we can to try and
bring nature back into our cities it's
been pushed
to a real breaking point um over
decades we've lost significant amount of
um
indigenous species and we're currently
facing about 4 000
species at risk or endangered with
at risk of extinction or endangered so
that's the sort of
broader position that we're in um and
the council
can play a core part in terms of turning
that decline
around um so
the i guess in terms of specific points
we acknowledge the work that the council
has done
through the the latest district plan and
and
some of the advocacy we're involved in
that in terms of ensuring that
significant natural areas are mapped
um and had a look today and can see that
there are particular areas that have
been mapped and that's successful so to
want to commend the work that the
council has done in that
in that area and the
encouragement i would say is to continue
to focus on that ensure that there is
the adequate skills and personnel on
staff
with ecological expertise to work with
land holders to ensure that those areas
are recognized and protected to ensure
that we don't face further
decline and noting that there's
hopefully going to be more guidance
coming out on
significant natural areas this year with
the national policy statement on
indigenous biodiversity
as well alongside that to
ensure that those areas are looked after
would really encourage the council to
set aside funding specifically for
biodiversity funds that community groups
can
tap into or land holders can tap into
to replant areas um undertake
trapping activities on on their land and
in their communities
as well um and ensure that the council
itself
is adequately funding pest and predator
control on the
reserves that it that it owns and it's
responsible for
as well and when it comes to that
planting um
we would really encourage a focus on
planting indigenous species
um rather than exotic forestry i know
there's not huge amounts of exotic
forestry in the
in the bounds of the city um but
wherever possible encouraging
um indigenous planting
when it comes to recognizing climate
change
um it's never too late for the council
to acknowledge and
um and uh acknowledge the climate crisis
that we are
working on and join the number of other
councils who have declared a climate
emergency
um and recognizing that the central
government has also
declared that so we've seen a huge shift
in this area
and the climate commission has has
produced some really good draft advice
when it comes to this
and the challenge that we're facing with
it is huge and will require
all of us to do all we can to first
instance reduce emissions as much as we
can
and then look to mitigate
what's left and when we are undertaking
those mitigation activities
ideally focus on plant and indigenous
species as well
some practical things that the council
can do
is you know evaluate its own emissions
profiles and look to reduce those
in terms of you know investing in evs
for its own car fleet uh encouraging you
know
the use of building more ev charging
stations around the city
and looking at you know some things like
that don't necessarily cost a huge
amount of money but can be very useful
for the residents in terms of
uh interest-free loans for um
you know solar panels and improving you
know
heating and whatnot and in the homes
around the city
as well as that uh looking at how uh on
on your own reserves you can you can
undertake
restoration plantings and whatnot as
well so i'll probably
wrap it up there and heavy to take any
questions
thanks rick councillors open for
questions councillor pottinger oh thank
you
uh birdlife now an invercargill is that
is that increasing and what i'm using as
an example
is zealandia up in crory and uh
how that the bird concentration there
has
has expanded out into the community yep
um
we have we got any phenomenon like that
or
does it just come and go in invercargill
there's no
do you actually measure the native bird
life i know that
cats are a problem and and i've engaged
a cat deterrent on my brooklyn
property yeah so um
zlandia has been an incredible asset for
wellington i lived there for a number of
years
um and before zealandia um
existed the biodiversity in the city was
reasonably dire
um but the council did play a pivotal
role in getting the likes of zealandia
off the ground
and as far as i'm aware there isn't any
uh
particular predator you know similar
predator-free zones within the city that
would
that would have the same effect um in
terms of ensuring that there is that
real
um safe place for those birds to to
breed and get to a critical mass that
they then spill out over into the rest
of the city
in terms of the specifics um of them of
the
monitoring i'm not particularly familiar
um
with invercargill city um
but doc and mfa do undertake that in the
environment
reporting which does look at um how our
species are doing across the country as
well
now the reason i ask that is be in a
terrible terrible position
to be everything's disappearing and then
go oh [ __ ]
yes yeah and and what we whenever
a new state of the environment report
comes out all the indicators are
generally negative
um and there is a you know a huge amount
of work that goes into
reducing the amount of predators but we
also need to make sure that their
habitats are protected as well
um to try and turn around that decline
so it does take a while to turn around
the decline
thanks rick thanks councillor clark yeah
thank you chair um rick
thank you for your submission um are you
aware that our parks and reserve
team have a sort of medium-term project
to
plant one native tree for every
population base that we've got um
they're they're working on an assumption
that over a period of time they'll
plant somewhere between 40 and 50 000
natives in the city
oh that's that's great here i wasn't
familiar with that so yeah
that works well underway yeah great
thank you
thank you thank you council is there any
further questions
if not rick uh again a detailed
submission thank you very much for
the uh work that's gone into it and for
taking the time to turn up the site
we appreciate it
steve your arrival was very timely
welcome along
um
um good afternoon all and thank you very
much for giving me the opportunity to
speak to the long-term plan
i'm speaking on behalf of rugby
southland uh to the long-term plan
outline for rugby park
um my name's steve mitchell and i've
been employed as the general manager
for rugby southland for just over a year
on arriving in invercargill to start the
lockdown lifted in may 2020
with a focus to improve the operation of
rugby southam both on and off the field
excuse my puffing i just marched again
straight from training
just about yeah so
yeah to help rugby southern both on and
off the field after previously being
employed as the operation manager for
the tasman rugby union
for the previous six years um just a
little bit of my background so during
those previous six years tasman had
become arguably the most successful
provincial union
in new zealand both on and off the field
winning the national provincial title
twice
building substantial reserves and
providing a recognised pathway to the
next level opportunities for all of
their
players jasmine also led the way with
several clever initiatives at community
rugby level
and hosting the first ever all-black
game in nelson under a new financial
model
so it was a fairly exciting time and a
time we're
proud to be involved and hope to bring
that skill set down here
after achieving my personal and the
organisational goals of tasman i was
looking for a new challenge
and helping southland as a struggling
provincial union excited me and was well
aligned with my skills and passion
and i was thrilled to be offered the
role
before my employment at tasman rugby
union i was employed as a senior advisor
for community sport for sport tasman
whilst in this role we had a huge focus
on the redevelopment
and operation of sustainable
multi-community facilities
over eight years at sport tasman i
advised undertook feasibility studies
governed and facilitated the development
of multiple facility projects
both locally and cross across new
zealand
saxton field and nelson is well known
for multi-use provision into
and to international standard
my rugby my own home rugby club the
mighty rangers
from upper motori had driven the
building of mootree hills community
complex
which was recognised by sport nz as a
template for rural
rural facility development around 2007
and after being a key contributor during
the design and building phase i became
the chairman for the first years of
operation
until the model was proven financially
sustainable
14 years old i'd be about 14 years on
mootree hills is still providing
excellent opportunities for all of its
residents
and continues to improve on available
activities and the standard the
facilities provided
so just to sum that up rugby and
community multi-use facilities
are a personal focus area that i've had
extensive experience in
and often i've been at the leading edge
in new zealand
um locally well rugby is an important
part of the fabric in new zealand
society and not more so than in the
provincial union such as southland
rugby is also the highest participation
sport in southwest
and has a proud and strong history in
this region
on arriving in vicargo and invercargill
one of my first focuses
was to look at the facility provision
for rugby and southland
and our flagship team the southern stags
as a successful business and a happy
work family both require a good home
so then we get to um rugby park
the current situation at rugby park is
that the supporters club rugby southland
office and the effective grandstands
are stated as unsafe the supporters club
can enter their own
at their own risk and signage is to be
displayed stating the same
the rugby southland officers were
completely stripped of wall and ceiling
panels
last june and the water egress continues
to be an issue
the concrete wall of where the water is
gaining excess has deteriorated further
as has some of the steel work no further
work has been undertaken in the offices
since they were stripped of their lining
some nine or ten months ago
the board of rugby southland have stated
that no staff
players or visiting teams can access
these areas
until they are deemed safe and council
informers so
senior staff at rugby south may informed
informed me that i'm the third general
manager from rugby southland
who's spent time and energy towards
driving a solution at rugby park
only to have nothing actioned the staff
are despondent
and do not believe that their concerns
are well and wellbeing
are being fairly considered the current
community and unsatisfied staff are they
the housed in the discarded netball
pavilion
established as a temporary measure which
is now heading towards its third year
the checkered history resulting in the
current state of rugby park is well
documented and understood by most here
the water egress issues were originally
identified at the completion of the
building
revisited in 2015 and 2019.
it's extremely disappointing for
everyone that no remedial action has
been implemented to the state
it will serve no purpose to outline the
history that caused the ongoing issues
at the rugby park but the lack of
progress and program
program maintenance continues to have a
detrimental effect on the usage and
condition of the facilities
the independent report to council
outlines that undertaking remedial work
at rugby park is the best option towards
ongoing provision of an outdoor stadium
for southland for the next 15 to 20
years
what i would propose is a solution that
involves effective collaboration
and a common goal based on mutual
understanding
regardless of which plan we choose to
follow it will require a combined vision
of an effective outdoor stadium
regularly used by multiple user groups
from the wider community with anchor
tenants in place
and catered for effectively this is
imperative at this stage
if we're to improve the current
situation and align with modern
stadium management concepts
rugby southland supports stage one of
the council long-term plan
making the facility structurally safe
and completing the deferred maintenance
this should be as implemented this
should be implemented as soon as
possible
we would voice our concerns over the
concurrent proposed time frame
it is imperative that rugby south and
staff secure suitable offices in the
immediate future
staff well-being productivity and morale
are negatively affected by the current
situation
and we need a solution or definite plan
now
if there can be no guarantee that the
remedial and program maintenance can be
implemented before the 2022
bunnings mpc rugby south and staff will
be prepared to move back to the stadium
and utilize the corporate boxes and
other rooms deemed safe
until the required repairs are completed
this concept was first implemented when
the toxic mould issue was first
identified
and only came to an end when the mitre
10 cup composition started in 2019
we are currently contributing lease and
power costs for this facility while
we're not on site
and discussions with senior staff they
would prefer to be housed this way
rather than the current situation and
this concept can be actioned immediately
without major costs staff will be
prepared to work around game day
requirements
as needed and we still get back to our
historic home
running this requirements for the stag
representative season will be easier to
implement and much
less disruptive for the staff if we are
on site at rugby park we call that plan
a if the timeline of the deferred
maintenance and repairs to the building
are not able to be implemented in 2024
25 then we need another plan the staff
can't stay where they are
for plan b i suggest that we consider an
option to place temporary relocatable
buildings on site
to act as rugby southland officers
saving ratepayer money for the rent that
counseling having to pay currently
and getting the rugby southland team
back on site as soon as possible
the capital investment should hold value
until the building is no longer required
this will be once the stadium repairs
are completed and allow for the use of
the office
supporters club and grandstands safely
other two preferred options outlined
should be considered stage one
as a lead into stage two which i
consider further development of the park
i request that council consider the
establishment of a specific committee
made up of operations and governance
from both user groups and
council to work on a strategic reset of
the park
towards multi-use so it benefits the
wider community
and becomes an asset that the potential
of external funding is considered as a
collective
and an mou is drafted between rugby
southland and icc
to engage and work towards a
redevelopment plan for the whole stadium
that could be completed in further
stages
this concept is requested to commence in
the first year of the long-term plan
and would involve revisiting the current
ownership of the facility
as the current trust clearly has no
money and limited capability to maintain
the facility
currently council funds are allocated to
the management and upkeep of rugby park
250 k per annum
150 k is distributed to invercargill
event management and 100
k to the invercargill
cct charitable community trust is that
correct
and 300k per four years for program
maintenance
it's hard to see the benefits of this
allocation and with only 23k of the 300k
allocated towards maintenance utilized
it's easy to understand the current
state of the building but it also raises
questions over who's responsible
and what works being undertaken rugby
southland have experienced ground
maintenance event management and
marketing staff who all hold a vested
interest in the presentation at care of
rugby park
and who are willing to work
collaboratively to ensure the ongoing
success and sustainability of this
facility
i am personally willing to use my
experience and contacts within the wider
rugby community
to assist with the project as a
component of my current role
improving rugby provision in southland
the rugby community unanimously
want rugby southland back at rugby park
and are willing to help we have skills
vested interest and the capability to
assist council
on the journey to develop and manage an
effective outdoor stadium
for the benefit of the wider southland
community
once again thank thank you for the
opportunity and thank you
for considering my views i'm willing and
able to answer any questions
thanks steve if only we hadn't gone to
10 minutes
sorry is it a quickie it's a very quick
question excellent
i note that the plan a and b that you
have in your
paper that you've read out is not in the
information you've provided to us in
your submission are you able to provide
a copy of that please certainly
excellent thank you thanks steve we
appreciate that
and uh look forward to receiving that so
that we can include that as a
as a part of your submission counselors
that brings us
to um a quick 10 minute break um
please we've got mr harper here ready
he's scheduled to be presenting to us
at uh 20 to 4 and i want to be underway
then thank you we're a journey
and i'll reconvene the hearing
wayne not unfamiliar circumstances
for you in this room welcome along thank
you for your submission
um you're used to the process so the
floor is yours
thank you mr chairman um yeah my switch
is predominantly around the blanket
sorry could you just make sure you
direct that microphone over
that's it cool thank you thank you uh my
business um
submissions put on around the museum and
art gallery and
um and the financial prudence um thereof
um with the upgrade that's been proposed
um and i don't expect anybody to
understand building costs or
or building techniques etc etc but
i think we should be using some sort of
touchstones to work out what
what the costs are involved in these so
i use a
software a program called qv cost build
which is used in our industry to um to
which develops our costs of
facilities and under the uh the current
um cost builder
um art galleries museums um
up to two stories the galleries work
areas small office amenities
uh vac sprinklers slow lifts security
and high level finishes
are stated around four and a half
thousand dollars a square meter
and the money that's been proposed to
spend it
at the current museum is over ten
thousand dollars a square meter
and i just can't get my head around uh
while i spend that much money um on that
to get a building which is still only 67
of the standard
um so from a financial prudence from
the decision making around going down
and down down their path
also then align that back to your
comments around play to stay et cetera
on the cbd and the about money that's
inspired in the
cbd area and um which
further um encourages me to
i think that we should be looking at
spending that sort of money in the cbd
and to to align with your play to stay
um philosophies
um so that's the the basis of where of
where um
again that's um i'm looking for more
from a financial side and i know you've
got to weigh up
community expectations and those sorts
of things as well
but i think that i just wanted to
highlight those
um those sorts of figures
the other side of that as well as the
the funding of that um
the other part of my submissions around
um the inventor city council i believe
paisa
um and the indigo city rate payers as
such
pays an exorbitantly high percentage for
the regional facilities
compared to the rest of southampton and
if we go
right across the rest of the country and
to um
into otago into wellington et cetera
they use the regional councils to
help those funding mechanisms and to
to spread that load and as the further
obviously got out so
when they built the um four-sided valve
stadium people to throw away as
queensland paid they didn't pay as much
as a
leading person but they still pay the
percentage and i think
the invoca rate payer is continually
dipping into its pocket for rugby park
for stadiums for velodromes
um swimming pools and and and now
um with the museum and art gallery as
well
seems that that it's the southern museum
in our gallery
but it's now basically fully funded by
invercargill
i was a member of the invercar of the
south and museum ratepayer
uh south new zealand gallery board
and that at that time now we were it was
represented by
gore and by um and by southland and
and the others and now none of that's
the case the big dollar is going to be
spent
and the indica rate power is one that's
going to dip into the
into the pocket for that so no matter
where it gets built
um we've got a regional council um here
which has got
was which is gifted a very large asset
in southport
it uses that in my opinion it uses that
asset
to subsidise rates rather than
supporting the um the wider
uh the wider community and um i think
that
this council should be spending a lot of
time to lobbying that group
and pressuring them to be honest into um
picking up some of the mantle and the
regional facilities
um i'm an avid um you know follower of
sport
around the area and we go to the go to
rugby park or to the
door to the stadium um very large
percentages of people
of the clientele from others out of um
in the cargo and i know i see one report
on the on the uh netball crowds on the
54
uh of the crowd that netball is from out
of indica
um yet still the cargo rate power which
is um
footing all that um how a lot of that
cost
um so yeah that's the basis of my
um submission and we'll take questions
thanks wayne
um i don't disagree with your position
around regional facilities uh are you
considering making a submission to
environment southland's long-term plan
which has just gone out for consultation
as well
i understand you you're asking us to
lobby them vigorously but
i i hadn't considered it in fact i
considered today my retirement
um from politics totally but
i'll i will consider that last hour
thanks wayne councillors councillor
clark yeah thank you chair uh wayne
just putting aside the issue of the uh
um
four and a half thousand versus the ten
which i i accept
uh and that's something certainly that
i'll take into consideration
just want your view on on location i
know you've previously
declared lower s street but um
are there other options that you think
away from queen's park or should queen's
park be
or gala street be the preferred location
if there was to be a new build
my restaurant around laura history is as
a museum in my mind is around
researching uh looking at your history
doing those sorts of things and to me
um that precinct when you've got the um
the library next door you've got the
archives next door
you've got those other facilities to me
it it becomes to me a community of
interest
around that and um and i think that the
i'm not i'm not anti the um down the
queens park facility and i think it can
be used for something whether it's an
art gallery or something else but i
don't think
i don't think it's the best place for a
museum because i think people come in
also with the amount of money that's
sincere and the cbd and trying to
enhance that with the car parking that's
going to be in there which will be
quite significant um and the fact that
when people go to the to the museum um
they can spawn families as well the
young ones can go one way in the
parents can go another and you can get
that um so to me it's
it's it's that community of interest um
around those other facilities and
they're very
very close by um when i was on council
previously we used to get a lot of
reports on the museum and again about
the
foot traffic and the people going
through the clicker at the door
but they never put the clicker was
always at the door where the
um where the um
they never ever wanted to put the
clicker on the door into the museum
yeah because they and it was known very
widely that
the bulk of the people were going were
going to the eyesight and uh
and again that's another part of the in
my lower history proposal is that
the eyesight is a natural i think you
fit there it can be
fitted in there perfectly with the
rockne place toilets as the entrance
into the
uh into the um into the museum night
gallery
it's it's to me it's the perfect um it's
the perfect uh
lunch you can get buses coming into that
area the buses are actually riding the
cbd you've got the hotels you've got the
new landlines going you've got all those
to me it just
again it fits into the plan and i know
there's a lot of emotion around the
museum where
it is but you get a way of motion with
practicality and with and with financial
and and it's a hard
it doesn't have you it's a hard hard
choice
but i just want to i think i wasn't very
comfortable not
advocating for her thank you for that
thanks wayne if i can ask a question
around the 10 000 per meter
square is it possible that price
includes
demolition before construction as well
and
exhibition fit out it's possible it does
confirm some exhibition stuff and um
when i made some um um
in the previous violence and i put some
figures out and i actually added in
another
um uh quite a consensus c4
demolition um as well so but i
understand this
demolition's going to happen anyway in
lower esque so again i didn't factor as
a major issue
um but and again the seconds of hackers
they're easy to you know i'm just
what i'm saying is this is what um this
is what the figures are by
the people and i checked those figures
as well when i was
going through the process of putting
this together i
scanned newspapers and i'd see a museum
in dunedin
or a library deleted built of x square
meters i
just extrapolate the the cost of the
of the library against the square foot
and and figures were sort of
matching up around that four and a half
to six and a half thousand
um so that was the thanks councillor
partner thank you
um just a quick one wayne were you aware
of the makeup
of that 51 million dollars
uh yes i was i took it based on the
inflation by the report that came out
they're the 26 8
6 and 6 and 5. yeah you already knew
that
yeah counselors any further questions
if not thanks very much wayne sorry with
that that tricky little bit at the end
that i've
not made it your swan song but uh yeah
just to
just finish it just like you pass on a
commendation and i
uh submitted here the things last year
about the building consensus process
just like to commend the city council
for the um
the improvements they've been vast and
uh like department of staff the
gratitude from the industry um as well
for um
it's a pleasure doing business online
rather than the other side of the show
it's for your your staff as well so
thank you thanks we appreciate that
vicky
sorry holly
sorry oh yes okay
good afternoon your worship the mayor
counsellors and council staff
my name is holly and i am here to talk
what
i would like to do for the town
playgrounds
i love i would love a couple
of ginormous playgrounds for everyone
and in in the neighborhood playgrounds
need more seats
picnic tables barbecue plates picnic
tables maybe
a barbecue or two and a sign that sticks
in the ground that
says pick up your water and the more
rubber spins
it will hopefully stop the big big kids
from high school littering
in town in town i would
like to see some places to play and
have some quiet spaces in town around h
j smith and other places in town
this would make me more interested in
coming to
town skateparks
it feels like it's it's
is squished in a small space
and the blankets come and take over it
my dad doesn't like it and i don't like
it either
it would be good to have a really
amazing one that has
lots of
kids that are not taking over it the
wanna
and arrowtown ones are amazing it would
be
good if it could have six pic
six picnic tables to
museum i would like
um i would like it
to be open weird is and also
what i like is that the cafeteria was
bigger so more people can come
and visit and have fun
plants more plants around queens drive
and other spaces that have grass
that you need to know so you don't have
to mow and so you can
have more native trees birds
and plants and you don't and you can
explore them and don't map them up
what i like about
what i like is that we
have the museum open again if we can
and it would be good
and and it would be a
pleasure if we could get everything done
this year or the next year and i like
this glance
for the town thank you for listening to
my submission
thank you holly and thank you for making
it unlike voting
uh making a submission to the city
council is not something that is
restricted around age
so what you have to say is just as
important as every other person that
we've listened to
over yesterday and today and it's very
you've thought a lot about it
um and you're obviously very passionate
about it and and that's
really good thank you very much for that
counselors open for
questions if there are any counselor
amundsen
and then councillor scout thanks mr
chair
um holly i was just wondering because we
can't do everything all
at the same time which of those things
that you talked about would be the thing
you would like to see
happen very first it'd be good to get a
skate park or the museum open again
with either of those two thank you
councillor sculpt thank you fuchsia um
thank you holly
fantastic to have the youth represented
today um i just wondered about the
museum
what are some of the other things that
you and your friends
might like to see in a new museum
is that a bit tough yeah a little bit
but my mighty help
yeah more fun
things to have some more fun on and
explore
so you like interactive things things
where you can push buttons
yeah exciting and moving yeah and maybe
a choose a hunt or something like that
well treasure so like science museum
stuff and yeah councillor crackit
and is that like the discovery world in
dunedin is that what we're thinking
lots of interactive displays and lots of
things to play with lots of science to
learn
and we miss the um the treasure hunts
that they used to have every school
holiday
yeah that was a real favorite so there
is a treasure hunt
that starts at hawaii
yep councillors was there anyone else
um sorry do you happen to have been to
the margaret mahi playground in
christchurch
no no okay thank you but you said would
put the
ginormous playground yeah yeah excellent
perfect
cool thank you very much holly we really
appreciate the fact you've come along
and made a submission this afternoon and
as you could tell everybody was
listening hard to what you had to say
so thank you thank you thank you very
much
mum
all right my turn
all right kia ora
uh kyoto worship the mere councillors
and council staff
uh kohia te manga kaiti
so my name is vikki henry and i'm
submitting as a
resident and as a proud mum thanks for
the opportunity to talk about the
long-term plan there's a whole lot of
good stuff in there
um the romantic renewal looks really
good and without taking away from that
there's a few points that i want to
raise
the arts and creativity project i'd love
to see that pulled forward
is that we see a difference from other
cities
and we've got quite a wealth of talent
down here that can be
featured iko holly's thoughts on play
spaces and
the cbd and welcoming families into it
and another ginormous playground and a
skate park like wanaka would be
fantastic um we'd even sort of talked
about it being in the
queen's park area on the corner of gala
in queens drive where
people go past it all the time and
that's one of the keys for skate parks
is that it's very public
very open lots of people just happening
to go past
um you know we talked about bike bike
um tracks and um bike pump trucks and
stuff like that
um but my biggest focus for the
long-term plan is um is really the
the lack of a clear climate change
policy i believe you've heard that a
little bit over the last couple of days
someone
mentioned um i know that it's mentioned
as part of your key activities
um but it seems to be in context of
managing council assets
there's a mention of having a plan
within the next three years while
working alongside environment southland
but i see this as planning to have a
plan
we've got until 2030 to limit global
temperature increase to 1.5 degrees to
avoid the worst impacts
of climate change but we're reaching
those tipping points earlier and earlier
as signatories of the local government
new zealand climate change declaration
in 2017 i'm sure this isn't news to any
of you
but to not have a plan or policy in
place by now with the knowledge that
we've got
and the risk that we face is i don't
know what
that is climate change is referred to in
many of the action plans under the
long-term plan i had a good dig around
and look
but mainly again it's in terms of asset
protection and mitigating the effect on
council activities
but there doesn't seem to be any clear
plan to mitigate the impact of
council activities on the climate
no clear goals objectives allocated
resources or measurement of emissions
if climate change is the number one
issue kiwis are worried about
and it's mentioned within council
reports and action plans and why isn't
there a policy
that's too big an issue not to have
clear pathways forward on by now
auckland city council long-term plan 21
20
to 2031 harbin green uh greenhouse gas
emissions
by 2030 carbon neutral 2050.
christchurch city council have changed
their carbon neutral goal from 2050 to
2030.
dunedin's net zero carbon gold by
and wellington and nelson have
comprehensive plans to reduce emissions
and we're planning to have a plan
there have been attempts to introduce
new targets and measures within some of
their action plans they had a good luck
but without a clear overarching policy
there's going to be piecemeal
and somewhat tokenistic we need clear
science-based policy plans
with budgets and ambitious time frames
let's write the policy let's make these
goals let's set the targets
and then let's get on with it at speed
we can be the city with the most street
trees in the world
let's think bigger than if a new
development needs a few more trees
then we're going to have to remove them
from elsewhere which is written into the
action pan
under the parks and reserves
because we want to avoid ongoing costs
this is not the right thinking
let's add tree plan we've got one
evidently i couldn't find
it let the tree plant say there's no
limits
on the number of trees let's protect
what we've got and plant a whole lot
more
as one of the simplest and best actions
we can take to
address climate change we can be the
city in the world with the least places
to mow
let's think bigger than planning to
increase our mine hectares which is
again an action plan let's plant the
median strips
let's plant the berms in the verges with
height appropriate natives
and create biodiversity corridors
throughout our city and surrounds
less mowing less pollution less spraying
and we get more wildlife more rare and
endangered plant support
and improved carbon sequestering we can
be the first city in the world to have
no
coal-fired boilers this is a hugely
impactful step to lower our carbon
emissions and it supports local
businesses such as falls
who are leaders in this field and i know
there's a background project
with the wood burning around town
there's been an amazing amount of
positive collaborative work going into
the carbon neutral southern project
it's a powerful project and it shows
that the future is very positive
so let's stop planning to have a plan
and get on with it it doesn't need to be
hard
all the information is out there we can
just pick and choose the actions
to suit us imagine if we invested in
real actions against climate change
electric buses electric vehicles for
council passive house quality housing
for council housing options
better outcomes for the residents lower
emissions by 90
over the building's lifetime water
fountains everywhere so no more bottled
water
bike racks cycle and walkways
restoration planting along flood banks
and streams
and this is just to start please
lead the way please stop planning to
have a plan
and make an actual plan please value our
environment
for more than what it can give you think
of it as a balance sheet
we have to even it up you are in such a
great position to make real significant
difference please don't waste this
opportunity our time is running out
i don't want to be here doing this i
don't enjoy this
i don't want to be doing this in 21
i want to be inspired by you and your
plan
let the next long-term plan submission
from me
read nothing further to add
i know i'm over time it may finish on a
quote
you're not over time okay if that's what
the dinong was that was the halfway
point
oh cool so i finished on a quote from my
verbal submission that i gave
um if i'm not out of time i'll just go
back to one point i skipped
a very senior council staffer at a
retailer's meeting at the beginning of
consultation on city block
told us that south owners don't care
about the environment because we have
the highest number of gas guys and cars
in the world
but i think they are wrong southlanders
love their environment
we love getting out of monster and we're
concerned about habitat lost
about pest species about overfishing
clean water
wild and pines and we're scared about
climate change
so to finish i quoted my verbal
submission for the
investment in city block in july 2019.
studies around the world are looking at
sustainability and this should be the
guiding principle of every council
initiative
i have a seven-year-old sorry now nearly
nine
her life at 17 will be very different
from our experience
and i will do everything i can at every
opportunity
to change this outcome for her i want
her to have a future where water isn't
scarce
weather is an extreme and sea levels
haven't risen
climate change is written briefly into
our long-term plan
it is in every insurance policy it
should be informing our planning
every action counts every decision
counts
and 30 years when we look back on the
decisions we make today let's be on that
right side of history
moving with our time not the last of the
old dragging effect
let's be seen to be doing all we could
when we could
for our children's future for my
daughter's future
thank you thank you vicky councillor
partner um
climate change i want this is a question
around the ethics
of climate change and talk about
electric vehicles
solar panels do you think it right that
council well anyone should buy
those products evs or panels from a
factory
that uses coal powered electricity i
think that's quite a loaded question
no no no but i'm just saying the ethics
it's to do with ethics
we have ethics with our recycling yeah
we can't send out recycling somewhere
i think that in today's world it's
really hard to make a decision without
falling over ethics everywhere so i
understand no but if
they're burning coal to make those cars
if that is that
are they burning colder materials are
they burning coal to make petrol cars
no burning coal to make electricity i'm
just saying
is that fear is that ethics okay i just
want to know what the rules are
you know when we start you know where do
you draw the line
well i think we have to make some
choices don't we
so electric vehicles have lower
emissions and then we have to then do
our due diligence into how they're made
and also due diligence into where does
our power come from
so down here we have quite good things
now i'm talking about overseas where the
cars are made yeah yep so then my
question comes back to you is
well is there a difference between how
petrol cars are made and how electric
cars are made regarding coal
burning to make the cars because then
it's a big point
no that's that's okay that's giving me
the answer thank you
thanks vicky other questions councillors
there are none thank you very much for
coming along this afternoon we'll uh let
the proud mum leave the table
uh and be equally proud of yourself for
your submission too thank you
colin
welcome along colin
and councillors thank you for the
opportunity to speak
um i'm known to um some of the
councillors but um
i've lived in invercargill since 1969
i taught in a number of schools and
finished my teaching career as principal
of st
george school which is now fernworth in
2004.
in 2007 i started work at the southern
museum and art gallery
as coordinator of visitor and education
services with
responsibility for about half the staff
i have a very good understanding of all
aspects of the museum
in 2007 it was an exciting time
and one of the reasons for accepting the
job was the prospect of being involved
in the proposed
redevelopment sadly of course for a
number of reasons
this never happened i retired from the
museum
after five years in 2012.
firstly may i say i'm probably wasting
my time as it appears the decision on
the future of the museum
has already been made collection items
are already being packed up
ready for going into storage somewhere
unknown no doubt at a high cost
to enable work on the building to start
i believe the process is flawed
and the options presented in the
consultation document
are not in the best interests of our
city and province
in the case of the museum is not a road
map for renewal
it's a road map to 67 of renewal
which is not good enough
the ilt can demolish in these inner city
buildings and build a seven storey four
and a half star hotel for 40 million
dollars
but this council was planning to spend
52 and a half million dollars
on a patch-up job to bring a substandard
building
up to 67 percent of new building
standards
where's the logic in that it just
doesn't make sense
the current building is grown from the
original 1940s building
with each remodel being attached to the
previous structures
and this has affected the flow of the
building as well as the structural
integrity of the building something to
clarify
the current building is not a pyramid
it's a steeply pitched roof supported on
the external walls
and internal columns the roof
roof has some design limitations
and it leaked from day one
there's nothing that has been released
to the public that generates any
excitement
just fixing up an old building so that
it can be reopened
build a new one alongside and keep the
current building for storage
a new building could create some
excitement and enthusiasm
museums don't have to be boring with
glass cases of old stuff
we've had a glimpse of what can be
achieved with the world war one
exhibit there are some fantastic options
available
a glass floor over a relief map of
southland enabling visitors to walk
around
southland glassed off storage areas
where items can be glimpsed
along with watching conservators and
staff at work
at the moment the amount of stuff in
storage
is never seen by the public
technology such as large streams and
large screens
live streaming our weather if you can't
fix it
feature it a virtual aquarium with
cameras streaming our incredible sea
life
or a saltwater aquarium workshops
featuring conservatives working on the
collection
maybe even a commercial repair shop
like the one on tv an artist in
residence working
traditional skills with carving weaving
arts being created
partnerships with doc sit fish and game
and conservation groups to highlight
their work research facilities
things happening not just static
displays
from what i've seen so far that's been
released by the council
all are planning to do is fix the old
building
an education centre a good-sized theatre
to attract visiting experts and of
course
a great cafe opening onto queen's park
there are exciting examples in museums
around the world
as well as unleashing the creative
talents of our locals
if you want to attract funders where
would you put your money
fixing up an old building or being part
of an innovative
new development much of the preliminary
work for a new museum has already been
done
check out the storage area there's a
lovely model of a new design and a glass
case
it's the upside down pyramid one sadly
rejected but with a few tweaks
it could perform could form the basis of
a new building
please don't squander our money the
figures i've forwarded in my submission
for building a new museum do stack up
i've had the figures checked by an
independent engineer
and he stated that they would certainly
be in the ballpark for a new development
does the council even need to own a
museum
after all it's only recently established
that the council did own the building
look at inner city developments
do kmart the warehouse or farmers
own their buildings is there an
opportunity for someone else to build
a new museum for the council to lease
i'm sure there are options there where
it ends up as a lease to eventually
own the building and it spreads the
costs
over a number of years if you're
hell-bent on keeping the current
building
maybe sell it sell it for a nominal
amount get someone else to bring it up
to standard and lease it
as a storage option a lease option could
speed up the whole process
and with a well crafted lease it could
be a win-win situation
for a province don't join
short-change our city after the
disappointment of the closure of the
museum
we need a project to uplift and inspire
go on dream big
that's my submission thanks colin
councillor abbott yeah thank you for
that i haven't got the figures
that you suggested for a new build could
you tell me what they are
i'm relying on the figures for
that wayne harper provided okay
which is about six thousand dollars per
square meter
thanks for that
thanks councillor ludlow um
my question is uh so there's been a lot
of
concern that it's taken a long time to
get started on
the redevelopment of the museum
especially after the closure
and so lots of people have said in their
submissions that we need to get on with
it and we need to get on with it asap
um and they want it open sooner rather
than later so
what would you say to those people if we
were
to decide to go down the road of
building a new museum either on the same
site or in a different place
which is possibly going to take a wee
bit longer
i wonder how long does it take for the
kmart building
to be built anyone's got an idea it's
probably about the size we would need
for a museum
that's a gun paste design it's a
warehouse column
it is a warehouse but basically the
structure it's got an underground park
it's got and i appreciate there's a lot
of other bits and pieces in there
um how long is it going to take the city
council to build
their hotel we're not building a hotel
ilt sorry um so their construction
period
three years but five years of planning
before
a lot of the planning has already been
done hasn't it
no particularly on grounds
some work for the initial upside down
pyramid
there's been a lot of preliminary work
done yes but we don't know what's
that was version one councillor crackit
it was an inverted pyramid on the same
site
was that when i was a toddler
if you're if you're eight years old yes
um an answer to your question rebecca i
don't know
i'm not a construction engineer or
anything like that but
answering the question if
a new museum could be shown to have some
exciting
things in it i'm sure people wouldn't
mind waiting
in dunedin they waited while the setlist
museum
was redeveloped and
if the project is exciting enough people
don't mind waiting
i think they'll be disappointed at just
a reopened old building through the
questions
seemingly there are now colin thank you
very much for taking the time to make
the submission and for coming along to
present counselors my apologies for
mr downing
statement
is
around 2015 councillor crackit
2014-2015
so i'll let you i'll let you do the
maths on your age so that's 2009.
sorry i was looking at an article from
the paper in 2015. for me it's a blur
google 2009 innovative vision for museum
there you go
even younger could have got it for 24
million back to cricket
we don't like cricket we love it
thank you very much for uh taking the
time to come along and present to us
this afternoon gentlemen the floor is
yours
good afternoon this is peter dowling
here acting general manager of the
qriket association and i'm jerry ward
the chairperson of the south and cricket
association
the south and cricket association would
like to make an application to the
city's 2021-31
long-term plan in regards to maintenance
and upgrade of the queen's park creek
ground
southland is considered a minor
association
falling under the strategic decision
making
okay decision making
you can have a seat if you prefer off
the bigger district
otago and whoever gets final here say
being new zealand cricket
as a minor association we have an
extremely proud record
not just in our playing results but also
on the pathway that we have created for
staff
who have developed their craft with us
and progressed to much higher honors
both within new zealand
and overseas our junior participation
numbers across the city and wider
province have been
outstanding and never been better the
future looks promising
and as an association we've been able to
accommodate the covert crisis
and still deliver a quality experience
for our stakeholders
the jewel in our crown is the queen's
park venue
beautifully anchoring the south end of
the queen's park gardens an outstanding
pavilion an
indoor training center a wicket block
which is the actual plane surface
and i'll be talking a lot about grounds
which has an excellent rating
an aesthetic environment regarded by
many players who come here
to be amongst the best in the minor
associations in the country
but despite what you see under the
surface
we have a problem around 2013
14 i recall presenting here detangling
the need for urgent
drainage to the grounds as we had lost
our first class warrant of fitness
and we wanted this restored what this
means is that we're not able to host
otago representative games
that's with the vaults the means or the
sparks or the women's team
we can't actually host any cricket
higher than club cricket or
representative age
grade cricket back at that time the
council allocated one hundred thousand
dollars over two years to redrain the
ground
and this was extremely successful and
all stakeholders are forever grateful
for the amount of work and funding that
was provided to this
there is a handout amongst your notes
that just show lots of lines on a piece
of paper which are the drains themselves
so 10 meters apart
you're sitting lateral drains put in
running from the galda street end of
queen's park down towards the north end
and that's commonly known and
be referred to as the duck pond inn
this works extremely well but has
created a problem and that it pushes too
much water
from the northern end into the lower
duck pondy end and it's not getting away
quick enough creating a large
slushy area belief beneath the site
screens
and causing new zealand cricket who
completed an ordered on the ground
during the recent
otago walking game to withdraw any
further first-class cricket from the
city
this was the primary recommendation in
their report another two i will inform
you off shortly
this ponding of the water can be
rectified through several methods and
already the parks and reserves
principally chris mcauley
have worked really hard on trying to
find some solutions to this
they believe the area needs to have some
of the trees removed
behind the site screen particularly in a
large hitch that needs to be trimmed
back
to enable wind to get through there and
more sunlight
to access the damaged area ironically
just looking there 20 minutes ago
there's more sunlight there
than all season because the leaves are
off all those large trees
the root system has also damaged some of
the drainage along that
south end of queens park the drain
itself the big drain that has to take
all the water
away runs back across in front of the
indoor practice area and it simply can't
cope
or manage that water flow and if
anything it's
largely because the soil is around the
pipes rather than clean gravel
which a lot more clean gravel is
required in them
and also the size of the dispensing pipe
unfortunately in the lead up to the
recent auckland otago
game and including the game we had six
out of seven days of rain
which didn't help us or our reputation a
lot but it happens in cricket as you
know
and it caused that game to be finished
early
without a satisfactory result and quite
a lot of complaint from the associations
not so much from the players but those
that were administrating the game beyond
southland
it also made the southern times
headlines it also made the otago times
headlines
later in the month when the editor there
got
a copy of the review report written by
new zealand cricket
new zealand cricket aren't satisfied
with it and are going to come down and
meet with us
on the 26th of this month to discuss
how we solve this problem and what we
can do going forward they're not asking
for it to be solved immediately but they
do want some action
is what we're hearing so the drainage is
about 80 percent
right and about 20 percent wrong when i
last presented here it was the other way
around
and we certainly are grateful because it
does work
a second concern for the new zealand and
the new zealand cricket order was around
the need for those lateral drains i'm
referring to
to be levelled out and unfortunately
with the 13 of them thus sinking
as you would with any drain they've all
sort of dropped about an
inch two and a half centimeters over
that six year period
water does collect on them while it's
waiting to be drained but it comes
unsafe for a ball
to be fielded when it's coming across
a ground that looks a bit like phobos
straight on a good day which is full of
ripples
and it can cause the ball to bounce
dangerously in front of a player
or it can cause players to roll ankles
and things and there has been complaints
from players
around that and certainly in the new
zealand cricket report we had also
furnished a report
um with ground specialists to see what
was required at the ground
and those two things that i've talked
about were pretty evident
and i think the highlights or the
summary of those reports is included
in your notes around what's required
we do believe that this is more minor
works than capital investment
but essentially restoring our city's
venue to a first-class status
is essential for our residents who enjoy
quality sport
and we don't want to take that away from
them a third concern raised was the
quality of the electronic scoreboard
and this was a requirement also of
hosting for first-class matches
we had one and for a long time it worked
perfectly well
but we've been unable to use it due to
it rusting out
and then ability to find parts for it or
anyone who can fix it
we've searched the globe and most of
china as well
looking for some way of being able to
solve that problem and it can't be done
in recent times we've hired a smaller
electronic school board from speedy
signs
which is transportable but not meeting
the warren fitness
match conditions a new electronic board
has been quoted by monster vision
to cost sixty thousand dollars we have
received twenty thousand dollars from
the ilt towards
us and we have allocated twenty thousand
dollars for our own reserves towards us
and we ask the council to consider
contributing towards this asset as well
a condition of the warrant of fitness
for any match is the score must be
clearly seen from any part of the
playing ground
we do not see such a board being solely
for cricket and we'd like to
the ground to have more multi-purpose
use
last year we had the national pipeline
competition on that ground and it was a
great success
a scoreboard would have helped immensely
an electronic scoreboard would have
helped immensely
we could also see the possibility of the
city to surf or the riverton marathon
finishing in the city
maybe car shows or have a go days those
type of things
contributing towards its use it should
be an asset for the city we have 250
young children play there twice a week
during the week nights and ideally a
school board that has drawers and venues
or
locations for them to play on and also
some visuals of them playing coming up
on that board would be great
so in summary the original drainage that
was a strength for the ground and
greatly appreciated
has become a weakness and needs
rectified at the duck pond end only
the same lateral drainage is gradually
sinking causing a ripple effect across
the plane surface
and needs topping up annually for the
next few years to level the field and
that's just a sand and topsoil
composite probably just putting on an
inch each year and letting it work into
the ground
it's it's unsafe at the moment and
unless we rectify the scoreboard
situation which is an expensive asset we
won't get our warranty fitness back
so thank you very much for listening and
considering our needs
and peter and myself are open to any
questions thank you
thanks jerry so with the 20 000 get for
a scoreboard and the groundworks what
kind of amount
are we talking about um
can you swing that microphone around
i guess the groundworks are something
that the icc the parks and
have been looking at so we don't have
the exact figures but they certainly
quoted to us remove the trees was
around fifteen thousand dollars the
the drains which was the next next major
thing is
probably a similar figure to take the
top dirt off the ring drain
um so probably and then the 20 000 for
the scoreboard
a lot of the other work is just
increasing what they're doing around
it's not a financial cost it's just a
little bit extra work
for top dressing counselor sopa
thanks mr chair i just wanted to inquire
have you
looked at the criteria for applications
to the ac
to council's active community fund
yes this happened in the last week of
march
and we were given the hurry up by new
zealand cricket immediately after that
game and
peter came to the icc here and was told
to
very quickly submit an application
crystal so
in many ways we haven't analyzed it but
we did what was asked of us to get
something into you
um i think they were due on the ninth of
may or some what
so you have made an application to
active communities not
also not to active communities no you're
referring to this application
there might be funding in active
communities can i suggest you might want
to look at the criteria for the active
community fund
thank you thank you
councillors any further questions
councillor skelt do you um just the
scoreboard mobile scoreboard mobile
cryoscope i'd love a no mobile
scoreboard and we've looked at that with
monster vision
um i've also gone to otago and asked why
they spent a hundred thousand on one at
their ground and didn't make it mobile
for mona new park and ourselves and
norfolk
they don't travel well as the
understanding personally though i'd love
to see one for the whole city that
could be managed by someone that goes to
and it could be used for all those
events i just named it terratonga and
southland athletics and everything else
that we run across the town i think
uh would be a great asset really but
they have to be very carefully managed
as their understanding
yeah so that was the least not at sixty
thousand dollars though
nigel that's okay but um in the sense of
even it was
permanently parked there if the council
was to become a
um partner with you the opportunity of
putting our tutorials on as a business
model
that would be that would work for you
guys
being a partner would interest us and
being a principal investor and it would
probably want
those dates that we need
i wouldn't store it at southland cricket
i think it needs to be in a warehouse
and
i understand from its yeast is a wee bit
of technical skill someone needs to know
how to manage them
and set them up but i think personally
um the city of benefit
imagine burt monroe with a large screen
and those types of things would be
really good for the city
yes i was thinking around the event
promotion from the city's perspective as
well so yeah
just looking along those the opportunity
if south and cricket was uh
amenable to that and we'd certainly
contribute
back to it bearing in mind probably the
licensing trust would be a
part of it but they've already given us
twenty thousand dollars which we've
hidden in reserves yep stored
stored still there oh yeah still there
thanks jerry any further questions
if not jerry peter thank you very much
for uh your submission
which was in on time and for coming
along this afternoon to speak to it
thank you very much
oh sorry sorry all the attachments
referred to in these folders i'm not
sure if we just leave them for you too
yep we'll we'll take them from you
thank you
this time welcome along courtney thank
you
thank you for having me am i right yeah
the floor is yours
you've got 10 minutes we'll ring a bell
at five um that you don't have to stop
then
but if you get to the second belt we run
out of question time
yeah perfection thank you i'm sure i
won't be that long um
kia ora everyone my name is courtney
allison and i'm the community
development and operations manager at
south alive
and i'm just here to talk to south
alive's submission on your long-term
plan so thank you for the opportunity
um really we just wanted to submit a
high level to just um
keep that awareness and continue to
advocate for the equitable investment
across the city and the infrastructure
that the city council manages
the roadmap to renewal document is
obviously quite focused on the city
centre and a few other scattered
projects and we understand that that's a
focus for the council but we just want
to continue
to advocate um for the rest of the
suburbs in particular south invercargill
and to ensure that there is ongoing
investment
um put into that area i've just
highlighted in our submission
a few examples of the things that we
hear um as part of my role and as part
of what south alive does we engage with
our community a lot to hear what it is
that they want for their community and
what they want to
see for south invercargill and something
that comes up frequently
are improvements to russell square in
particular um a fence around the
playground area to keep it safer for
kids
um i'm i've got two young kids myself
and i know
the very real speed with which kids can
move and that playground is so close to
such a busy road
um and so many parents have raised that
with us when we've
had annual surveys public meetings um
just recently at
the pantry village market um i had a
stand there where i was just
wanting to hear what people loved about
south invercargill so i was having a bit
of engagement opportunity there
and people raised it again there that
it's a real safety concern
um for kids using that playground um
also through all of that engagement one
of the other things that has raised the
need for public toilets at that park
and there's also been concerns raised
about the trees creating
slip hazards and safety concerns along
that road too
um so that's just the kind of example of
the the investment and continued
interest we want to see in the south of
cargill area
um another example is around the
footpaths
um we have a lot of elderly people
coming through and using our space at
the pod
um and one of the things we hear about
is the accessibility
of different areas um one thing that was
raised by our senior friendship group
was
that would be great to know where all
the accessible sort of paths are a lot
of them use
they may not be in wheelchairs but they
may use walkers um and
just even um the accessibility where
they could go for walks with
their walkers and have those smooth
surfaces um i made some inquiries and
was
given a brochure that was maybe 15 years
old that had a few
accessible footpaths um
thompson's bush and anderson's house
loop were the ones that were given as
examples
and neither of those actually that user
friendly for people with
walkers so just some consideration to
that when um infrastructure has been
developed and and perhaps
it's just around promotion of areas that
are of that bit of standard
so those are just some of the examples
of the infrastructure and
attention that we'd like to see
continued in the south of the cargill
area
um on a more positive note we also
wanted to acknowledge and um
submit in support of the proposed
changes to the rating system
um that will see the lower
valued properties contributing a lower
proportion of the rates
um and yeah i've included our in our
submission some of the south and the
cargo deprivation measures which just
highlights the importance that um
taking that approach really means to our
community and you can see that the
the deprivation score for almost all of
the suburbs within the south of the
cargo area is
in that high deprivation area so a score
of eight nine or ten
there's only one that sits outside of
there and that's new field and that's at
a
level seven on the deprivation index
from one to ten so that's
some pretty high deprivation measures
that we're facing in south america and
so
any way to ease that financial pressure
is um supported
um and finally i just want to
acknowledge um and thank the staff and
councillors that came out to the pod
in south and vicar as part of your
engagement on this process we really
appreciate that you
traveled around the area and came to
south invercargill to do some of the
engagement on this
and made it yeah approachable and
accessible for people in our community
so i just wanted to thank you for that
as well
thanks courtney can i just ask about the
the the fence you're suggesting for
russell square
what what size of fence because at some
point there's going to be a concern
around
safety and security for people on that
playground
yeah um so i presume your park staff are
probably best equipped to
give some advice on what kind of style
of fencing but it's just something to
create
a barrier so that kids can't just
immediately run out
it doesn't even necessarily need to be
fully enclosed but just something to
slower
i could not too electric yeah not
electric no barbed wire perhaps
thanks courtney councillor rabbit yeah i
just want to notify that
south alive do sponsor a little program
on my radio show every day for community
services
there's no beginner interest they're not
charged i get no remuneration
but i just wanted to say i've had no
input into these
submissions thanks councillor councillor
manson
thanks i'm just uh wondering if we could
ask you about
the uh saving grace project and your
thoughts
around the level of need for a project
like that
to happen in south indica would it
support the work that you're doing
yeah so um south alive board was
involved in um
doing some of the preliminary work
around that saving grace project and um
our chair barrel was involved in doing
quite a bit of the youth consultation
around
the need for that and certainly the
board sees that there is a need for a
youth space all the engagement and
research that was done around that
identifies
that need yeah um
yeah so there's definitely the
consultation consultation was done with
number 10
schools um people that run youth gaming
events
there was yeah there was consultation
with a variety of people that involved a
new sector and
there was the feedback from that was
that there was a need for a space for
youth
um yeah our board isn't in a financial
position necessarily to
progress with providing a facility at
this point in time um
so we're trying to do a lot of other
activities in the new space that provide
potential services rather than a
facility itself but a facility
of some kind was demonstrated as a need
from that
research we'd be happy to share that
if needed thank you
further questions
lucky escape courtney thank you very
much for uh for your submission
and for coming along this afternoon we
do appreciate it thank you very much
guys says we've got one final submission
i think it was going to be by
zoom or phone so we're just
we're trying to get in touch with them
councillor scout he's already advised
that he said to leave councillor
crackit also has to you didn't tell me
i'm telling you now this school or what
no it's a much more statutory what
organization than school bye-bye you're
getting a bit ready there
excuse me
it's very rude
are we having this we're just uh are we
waiting for a bezel at ten two or can we
continue
i think we probably need to wait till
the time we can go into zone
you